EVERYONE TO TODAY'S JOINT
INFORMATIONAL HEARING IT IS
WEDNESDAY JANUARY THE THIRTIETH.
TWO THOUSAND NINETEEN THIS IS A
JOINT MEETING OF THE ASSEMBLY
HOUSING AND COMMUNITY
DEVELOPMENT COMMITTEE AS WELL AS
THE ASSEMBLY LOCAL GOVERNMENT
COMMITTEE.
I'M HERE WITH --
THE WONDERFUL CHAIR OF THE LOCAL
GOVERNMENT COMMITTEE WHO WILL
SAY A FEW OPENING COMMENTS
SHORTLY.
BUT I WANT TO THANK ALL THE
MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE THE
MEMBERS OF THE PUBLIC ON THIS
TOPIC.
ARE AN EXAMINATION OF X. CELERY
DWELLING UNIT LAW AND POLICY
ISSUES IN CALIFORNIA OTHERWISE
KNOWN AS NOT JUST YOUR GRANNIES
GRANNY FLAT.
I THANK OUR THE HUMOR OF OUR
STAFF FOR THAT --
LET ME JUST START BY SAYING WE
ALL KNOW THAT IN THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA WE'RE IN THE MIDST OF
THE MOST INTENSE HOUSING CRISIS
THAT OUR STATE HAS EVER
EXPERIENCED.
AYE AND DURING THIS TIME PERIOD
WE ARE ALL LOOKING FOR NEW AND
INCREASE SOLUTIONS TO MORE
HOUSING IN EVERY ONE OF OUR
STATE -- IT
WAS NOT LONG AGO THAT AT USED
FOR A THIRD RAIL ISSUE AND BY
THE WAY BY EXCESS REDRAWING
UNITS WERE TALKING ABOUT --
UNITS.
THAT ARE PART OF THE FOOTPRINT
OF THE BUILDING OTHERWISE KNOWN
AS IN LAWS OR GRANNY FLATS --
AND PART OF THE CHALLENGE.
AS WELL AS BECAUSE HE THIS.
THANK YOU SIR.
IT WAS NOT LONG AGO THAT THESE
UNITS WERE ILLEGAL ALMOST
EVERYWHERE AND ECAUSE THEY DID
EXIST --
THEY WERE OFTEN SUBSTANDARD --
AND WERE IN CONDITIONS THAT WERE
HAZARDOUS I WILL TELL YOU FROM
EXPERIENCE IN SAN FRANCISCO --
OUR CITY HAS HAD TENS OF
THOUSANDS OF FORMALLY ILLEGAL IN
LA UNITS ONE THE VERY FIRST
BILLS THAT I INTRODUCED AS A
LOCAL LEGISLATOR --
WAS A BILL TO LEGALIZE HE'S
UNITS BUT AT THE TIME TEN YEARS
AGO THIS WAS A VERY POLITICALLY
FRAUGHT ISSUE.
BUT IN RECENT YEARS EVERYONE'S
PERSPECTIVE I AND AT THIS POINT
THROUGHOUT THE STATE. EIGHTY USE
PART TECHNICALLY LEGAL --
BUT THERE HAVE BEEN MANY
CHALLENGES --
WHEN IT COMES TO ZONING AND
OTHER POLICY CONCERNS AND THIS
IS THE FOCUS OF TODAY'S HEARING?
OUT WHILE WE HAVE HAD MANY
CITIES THAT HAVE BEEN SUPPORTIVE
OF MOVING FORWARD THESE SORTS OF
UNITS THERE BEEN OTHERS THAT
HAVE BEEN LESS SUPPORTIVE.
THERE HAVE BEEN MANY FEES
DESPERATE FEES THROUGHOUT
JURISDICTIONS --
THAT'S WE ARE TRYING TO GRAPPLE
WITH AND UNDERSTAND THEIR MANY
BUILDING CODES AND OTHER ISSUES
THAT -- HAVE
CREATED INCONSISTENCIES BOTH
WITH LOCAL LAWS AS WELL AS WITH
STATE LAW SO --
WHILE WE'VE MADE SIGNIFICANT
POLICY TREATMENTS MOVING THIS
FORWARD AT THE STATE LEVEL AND
AT THE LOCAL LEVEL --
GIVEN THE CHALLENGES ON THE
GROUND WE WANTED TO HAVE THE
HEARING TODAY TO REALLY EXAMINE
THESE ISSUES --
AND BRING EXPERTS TO HELP US
SHAPE.
POTENTIAL POLICY SOLUTIONS IT
WILL BE CONSIDERING THIS YEAR SO
WITH THAT I WANT TO TURN IT OVER
TO THE CHAIRWOMAN OF THE LOCAL
GOVERNMENT COMMITTEE THANK YOU
FOR BEING HERE.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH THANK YOU CO
CHAIR ASSEMBLY MEMBER CHU I'M
ARE TO COMMITTEES TO SPEND A LOT
OF TIME TOGETHER THE PAST COUPLE
OF YEARS I EXPECT WE'LL BE DOING
A LOT OF THAT AGAIN THIS YEAR --
ONE OF THOSE AREAS WE SEEM TO
SPEND A LONG TIME UNLESS SHE WAS
EIGHTY USE.
A WHAT OCCURRED TO ME IN LOOKING
AT THE MULTIPLE EIGHT SOME BILLS
ALIGNED WITH THE GOALS THAT WE
WERE TRYING TO ACCOMPLISH.
OTHER BILLS DID NOT IN FACT HAD
POLICIES THAT WERE CONTRARY TO
EACH OTHER.
CLEARLY THERE ARE DIFFERENCES OF
OPINION ON HOW BEST TO APPROACH
EIGHTY YOU POLICY CHANGES.
I HOPE THIS INFORMATIONAL
HEARING HELPS EDUCATE OUR
MEMBERS ABOUT SOME OF THOSE
ISSUES LEADS TO MORE FRUITFUL
DISCUSSIONS ONCE WE START TO
HEAR BILLS IN THE NEAR FUTURE.
AS CHAIRMAN OF LOCAL GOVERNMENT
COMMITTEE I CONTINUALLY RAISE
THE ISSUE OF ONE SIZE FITS ALL
LEGISLATION THAT TREATS LOCAL
AGENCIES THE SAME WHEN IN FACT
EACH CITY OR COUNTY.
CAN HAVE VERY DIFFERENT HOUSING
NEEDS NEIGHBORHOOD FEEL
COMMUNITY NEEDS TO PONDER FREE
AND THE LIST GOES ON WHY SUPPORT
STATE WHY GOALS TO TO INCREASE
THE DEPLOYMENT OF EIGHTY USES
ONE WAY TO HELP EASE OUR HOUSING.
US SHORTAGE I ALSO SEE A NEED TO
MAINTAIN LOCAL FLEXIBILITY AND
HOW THOSE GO GOALS ARE IMPOSED.
I'D LIKE TO THANK ALL THE
SPEAKERS IN ADVANCE FOR TAKING
THE TIME TO SHOW THEIR X.
EXPERTISE ON WITH US ON THE
EIGHTY USE.
WE HAVE GREAT PANELISTS TODAY
AND THIS WILL GO A LONG WAY
TOWARDS ACHIEVING EDUCATION ARC
EDUCATION GOALS FOR OUR MEMBERS
AND WILL NEED FUTURE
CONVERSATIONS --
I WOULD LIKE TO ASK OUR SPEAKERS
TO STAY AWAY FROM DISCUSSING ANY
CURRENT LEGISLATION INSTEAD
FOCUS ON POLICY ISSUES
SURROUNDING EIGHTY USE.
WITHOUT ALTERNATE BACK OVER TO
ASSEMBLY MEMBER TO TO INTRODUCE
THE FIRST PANEL GREAT LET ME
JUST ASK IF ANY FAR COLLEAGUES
HAVE ANY INITIAL COMMENTS.
SCENE ON LET'S A ASK OUR FIRST.
WITNESS.
YES MISTER BLOOM HAS REITERATED
THAT EIGHTY USER GUIDE.
WHICH I THINK IS A CONSENSUS
PERSPECTIVE OF ALL OF US HERE
TODAY --
WE'D LIKE TO INVITE OUR FIRST
SPEAKER TO REVIEW OF EIGHTY YOU
LAW -- FROM
THE DEPARTMENT OF HOUSING AND
COMMUNITY DEVELOPMENT WE HAVE
GREG NICOLAS.
MISTER NICHOLAS.
THANKS FOR THE HOUSEKEEPING.
THEIR OWN ORDER LOOKS LIKE.
GOOD MORNING MY NAME IS GREG
NICOLAS AND I'M WITH THE
CALIFORNIA DEPARTMENT OF HOUSING
AND COMMUNITY DEVELOPMENT.
AND I'VE BEEN WORKING ON EIGHTY
YOU ISSUES SINCE LATE TWO
THOUSAND SIXTEEN FOR THE
DEPARTMENT AND WE APPRECIATE THE
OPPORTUNITY TO BE HERE.
DEPARTMENT HOPES ARE COMMENTS
WILL BE HELPFUL TO LEGISLATURE.
ARE.
A LITTLE BIT OF HISTORY ON
EIGHTY YOU CALIFORNIA EIGHTY YOU
LAW WAS FIRST ENACTED IN.
NINETEEN EIGHTY TWO EIGHTY LOS
STARTED BY GIVING LOCAL
GOVERNMENTS.
AUTHORITY TO PERMIT EIGHTY YOU'D
DWELLING UNITS WITH THE
CONDITIONAL USE PERMIT --
A DISCRETIONARY PROCESS THAT
EACH CD NOW OFTEN CONSIDERS A
CONSTRAINT ON DEVELOPMENT OVER
THE YEARS LAWS CHANGE IN
ATTEMPTS TO ADDRESS BARRIERS.
TO DEVELOPMENTS SUCH AS PARKING
AND UNIT SIZES --
BUT PAID CHANGES WERE PERMISSIVE
IN LIKELY HAD LITTLE IMPACT
THAT'LL CHANGE IN TWO THOUSAND
THREE WITH THE PASSING OF AB
EIGHTEEN SIXTY SIX WHICH
REQUIRES LOCAL GOVERNMENTS. TWO
MINUTES THEIR EARLY CONSIDER
SECOND UNITS NOW EIGHTY USE WE
GET ALL THOSE OTHER NAMES OFTEN.
THIS IS A BIG SHIFT TO THE PRIOR
DISCRETIONARY PROCESSES THAT
INVOLVE PUBLIC HEARINGS IN THE
REVIEW AND APPROVAL PROCESS --
IN RESPONSE TO A BE EIGHTEEN
SIXTY SIX AGAIN BACK TO TWO
THOUSAND THREE EIGHT CITY
RECEIVE CLOSE TO THREE HUNDRED
LOCAL GOVERNMENTS ADOPTED EDIE
YOU --
ORDINANCES.
WHICH WERE WHICH WERE SUBMITTED
TO EIGHT CD --
THE CURRENT OVERVIEW OF THE
EIGHTY LAW IN THE LEGISLATURE
CONTINUE TO REFINE AND CLARIFY
EIGHTY YOU LAW.
ON THE LEGISLATURE'S TAKING A
BIG LEAP IN ADDRESSING POTENTIAL
LOCAL BARRIERS EXAMPLES INCLUDE
PARKING IS IS A VERY LARGE.
ONE HE CAN BE A HUGE FACTOR --
AFFECTING FEASIBILITY AND COST.
EARLIER VERSIONS OF EIGHTY LAW
ALLOWED LOCAL GOVERNMENTS. TO
EXCEED ONE PARKING PLACE FOR
EIGHTY YOU BUT LAWS BEEN CHANGED
TO MAXIMIZE PARKING FOR AN
EIGHTY TWO ONE SPACE.
UNLESS THERE ARE EXEMPTIONS --
THE AS WELL AS ALLOWING
ALTERNATIVE PARKING SOLUTIONS
FOR THE EXISTING PRIMARY
DWELLING --
IF ANY DO YOU IS --
IS CREATED WITHIN THE EXISTING
GARAGE THE ALTERNATIVES FOR
PARKING FOR THAT PRIMARY
DWELLING --
ARE ARE ARE MANY.
I'M AT USE ARE EXEMPT FROM
PARKING REQUIREMENTS ALTOGETHER
IN SOME CIRCUMSTANCES SUCH AS
WHEN AN AT YOU IS --
IT WITHIN CLOSE PROXIMITY TO
PUBLIC TRANSIT.
LOCAL GOVERNMENTS ALSO CANNOT
ADJUST PARKING REQUIREMENTS BY
BEDROOM WHICH WAS IN EFFECT IN.
TWO THOUSAND SEVENTEEN NOW
EIGHTY YOU PARKING IS ONE HER
UNIT.
REGARDING FEES IN SOME AREAS OF
CALIFORNIA THERE ARE NO
ADJUSTMENTS FOR FEES FOR EIGHTY
USED DESPITE.
THE LESSER IMPACT OF THEIR FOOT
PRINT COMPARED TO A SINGLE
FAMILY HOME. FOR EXAMPLE
CONSIDER A TEN THOUSAND DOLLAR
TRAFFIC IMPACT FEE FOR SINGLE
FAMILY HOME.
HOW ABOUT THE IMPACT FEE FOR AN
EIGHTY YOU NEAR TRANSIT?
IN SOME JURISDICTIONS THEY ARE
POTENTIALLY THE SAME THERE'S NO
REDUCTION EVEN THOUGH.
THE EIGHTY YOU MIGHT NOT BE
REQUIRED TO HAVE PARKING. EIGHTY
LAW NOW TAKES THE FIRST STEP IN
ADDRESSING THE FEE ISSUE WITH
EXEMPTIONS FOR UTILITY FACE WHEN
EIGHTY USE CREATED WITHIN THE
EXISTING STRUCTURE --
REDUCTIONS IN SEWER AND WATER
FEES WHEN A NEW EIGHTY YOU
STRUCTURE IS CREATED SUCH AS A
NEW DETACHED.
STRUCTURE IN THE BACKYARD WERE
ATTACHMENT TO THE PRIMARY
DWELLING.
IN SOME JURISDICTIONS --
THERE ARE STILL WANTING TO
CHARGE THE FULL FEE FOR SEWER
AND WATER.
THE THE LAW DID CHANGE FOR LAST
YEAR INCLUDING SPECIAL DISTRICTS
FOR SEWER AND WATER CORPORATIONS.
TO ABIDE BY THE SAME
REQUIREMENTS.
EIGHTIES IN EXISTING SPACE OF
PREVIOUS VERSIONS OF EIGHTY LAW
ONLY ADDRESSED TO TYPE CITY TO
USE AN ATTACHED IT'S ATTACHED TO
THE EXISTING PRIMARY DWELLING.
OR DETACHED STRUCTURE NOW LAW
INCLUDES A THIRD CATEGORY THAT'S
THE CONVERSION OF EXISTING SPACE
LIKE A GARAGE CONVERSION OR RE
PURPOSING A SPACE IN EXISTING
HOME.
SUCH AS A MASTER BEDROOM THE
MIGHT ALSO BE DONE EIGHTY YOU.
IN ADDITION HAVING THIS NEW
CATEGORY THE LAW ALSO MITIGATE
SEVERAL POTENTIAL BARRIERS MOST
PROMINENTLY.
LOCAL --
CRITERIA CURRENTLY LOCAL
GOVERNMENTS.
I'M MAY DETERMINE WHERE AND HOW
TO ALLOW EIGHTY USE. FOR EXAMPLE
A LOCAL GOVERNMENTCOULD ALLOW
EIGHTIES ONLY ON LARGE LOTS AND
WE HAVE SEEN SOME OF THAT.
POTENTIALLY IMPACTING EIGHTY YOU
CAPACITY.
HOWEVER CURRENT STAY LAW ALLOWS
FOR THE CREATION OF EIGHTY USE
WHERE THERE IS A CURRENT.
S. SINGLE FAMILY HOME ON A LOT --
AND THE EIGHTY WAS BEING MADE
WITHIN THE CREATED WITH IN THAT
EXISTING STRUCTURE.
THESE CONVERTED SPACE AT USE ARE
NOT SUBJECT TO DEVELOPMENT
STANDARDS --
ZONING REQUIREMENTS ETCETERA
SUCH AS LOT SIZE HEIGHTS.
UNIT SIZE SET BACK SUCCESS --
GARAGE CONVERGENCE MANY HOMES OF
EXISTING GARAGES THAT MIGHT NOT
TO MEET CURRENT SETBACK
REQUIREMENTS DIRECTLY IMPACTING
THE FEASIBILITY OF CONVERTING
EXISTING SPACE HOWEVER. EIGHTY
LAW NOW SPECIFIES THAT NO SET
BACKS.
ARE TO BE REQUIRED FOR AN
EXISTING GARAGE WHEN IT IS
CONVERTED TO AN EIGHTY YOU.
OTHER THAN FOR SET BACKS FOR
FIRE SAFETY --
REGARDING EIGHT CD REVIEW
AUTHORITY --
EIGHTY YOU LAW NOW ALLOWS EACH
CD TO REVIEW AND COMMENT ON
EIGHTY ORDINANCES SUBMITTED TO
THE DEPARTMENT PREVIOUSLY THE
STATUTE ONLY REQUIRED EIGHTY
ORDINANCES JUST TO BE SUBMITTED.
TWO WITH THE DEPARTMENT.
LOCAL GOVERNMENTS HAVE PUT HAVE
GENERALLY BEEN RESPONSIVE TO THE
CHANGES AND EIGHTY LAW.
AND THERE ARE MANY POSITIVE
EXAMPLES OF INNOVATIVE OR
EFFECTIVE PROGRAMS THROUGHOUT
THE STATE.
FROM THE CITY OF LOS ANGELES TO
CLOVIS. TO SAN MATTEO COUNTY.
DAN TO CINEMA COUNTY AS PART OF
THEIR DISASTER RESPONSE. TO DATE
EIGHT CD HAS RECEIVED
APPROXIMATELY TWO HUNDRED
ADOPTED EIGHTY ORDINANCES IN
RESPONSE TO THE RECENT LAWS AND
THOSE WOULD BE THE LAWS.
AFFECTED THE FIRST OF TWO
THOUSAND SEVENTEEN WELL LESS
THAN THE THREE HUNDRED
ORDINANCES RECEIVED AS REQUIRED
BY AB.
EIGHTEEN SIXTY SIX THIS NUMBER
IS STILL A POSITIVE RESPONSE AND
SOME LOCALITIES MAY BE
SUCCESSFULLY FOLLOWING THE STATE
STANDARDS.
WITHOUT THE ADOPTION OF AN
EIGHTY ORDNANCE. FOR EXAMPLE THE
CITY OF LOS ANGELES THEY'RE
STILL USING JUST THE STATE
STANDARDS.
ALL THE LOCAL AGENCIES ARE
SUBMITTING THEIR ADOPTED EIGHTY
ORDINANCES TO EIGHT CD THE
ORDINANCES ARE POSTED ON THE
DEPARTMENT'S WEBSITE AVAILABLE
TO ALL WITHOUT REVIEW. EIGHTY
YOU ORDINANCES ARE ONLY REVIEWED
TO ADDRESS.
REPORTED POTENTIAL COMPLIANCE
ISSUES FROM APPLICANTS ADVOCATES.
AND OTHERS.
ATVS EFFORT TO RUN AT Là
GENERALLY FALL INTO THREE
CATEGORIES.
INFORMATION DISSEMINATION
TECHNICAL ASSISTANCE AND
REGULATION.
ON INFORMATION THE DEPARTMENT
HAS DEVELOPED A WEBSITE WITH
RESOURCES IMPOSE ALL RECEIVED
EIGHTY ORDINANCES AGAIN IT'S
ABOUT TWO HUNDRED TO DATE.
IT IS IMPORTANT TO NOTE THE
DEPARTMENT DOES NOT
COMPREHENSIVELY REVIEW ALL
ORDINANCES RECEIVED AND MAINLY
OPERATES.
ONLY ON AN INQUIRER BASIS WHEN
THE NECESSARY TIME CAN BE
ALLOTTED.
ON TECHNICAL ASSISTANCE THE
DEPARTMENT PREPARED GUIDANCE IN
THE FORM OF THE HANDBOOK WHICH I
THINK SOME OF YOU HAVE.
IN LATE TWO THOUSAND SIXTEEN
THAT ADDRESSED FREQUENTLY ASKED
QUESTIONS INCLUDED A MODEL
ORDINANCE FOR THE USE BY LOCAL
AGENCIES.
THE DEPARTMENT ALSO RESPONSE TO
CALLS FROM FROM A VARIETY OF
SOURCES TO DATE THE DEPARTMENT.
HAS DOCUMENTED MORE THAN. ELEVEN
HUNDRED INQUIRE IT'S AND I THINK
WE HAVE A LOT MORE THAN THAT FOR
TECHNICAL ASSISTANCE THESE A
PRIMARILY BEEN RECEIVED FROM
PROPERTY OWNERS THAT IS THE
MAJORITY.
APPLICANTS DESIGNERS AND
ADVOCATES BUT ALSO INCLUDES
OFFICERS FOR OFFICES THE MEMBERS
OF THE STATE LEGISLATURE AND
LOCAL AGENCIES. EIGHTY WORKSHOPS
HAVE BEEN CONDUCTED FOR SEVERAL
GROUPS INCLUDING THE CALIFORNIA
DEPARTMENT.
OF FROM THE CHOOSE ME THE
CALIFORNIA ASSOCIATION OF
BUILDING OFFICIALS.
THE NATIONAL ASSOCIATION OF
REMODELING AND DIEGO COUNTY
EIGHTY YOU STATUS CONFERENCE
WHICH INCLUDED.
LOCAL ELECTED OFFICIALS AND
PLANNING MANAGERS.
THE SANTA BARBARA CHAPTER OF THE
AMERICAN INSTITUTE OF ARCHITECTS.
THE SOUTH CANDY ECONOMIC
DEVELOPMENT COUNCIL SAN DIEGO.
THE GATEWAY COUNCIL THE
GOVERNMENT FOR PLANNING
DIRECTORS IN THE LOS ANGELES
AREA AND OTHERS.
ATV IS PROVIDING THE REVIEW
SERVICES FOR DRAFT AT ORDINANCES
AS REQUESTED BY LOCAL AGENCIES
PRIOR TO ADOPTION AND I'D SAY WE
PROBABLY.
IT REQUESTEDBY LESS THAN A HALF
OR LESS THAN A DOZEN.
LOCAL AGENCIES TO REVIEW THEIR
DRAFT ORDINANCE BEFORE THEY HAVE
ADOPTED THE ORDINANCE.
ON THE REGULATORY SIDE EIGHTY
REVIEWS ADOPTED ORDINANCES AS
COMPLIANCE CONCERNS ARE REPORTED
BY APPLICANTS OR OTHERS AND
PREPARES COMMENTS LETTERS TO
INFORM LOCAL AGENCIES OF
REVISIONS THAT MAY BE NECESSARY.
TO MEET THE REQUIREMENTS OF LAW.
THESE LETTERS ARE AVAILABLE
MODERATE CD WEBSITE JUST AS THE
ORDINANCES ARE.
HOWEVER THERE ARE NO ENFORCEMENT
PROVISIONS IN EIGHTY LAW.
THE REVIEW AND COMMENT AUTHORITY
IS FAR DIFFERENT FROM EIGHTIES
AUTHORITY TO REVIEW AND
DETERMINE COMPLIANCE.
AND IN FORETELLING ELLEN LET
SUCH AS ENFORCING HOUSING ABOUT
LAW. FOR EXAMPLE WITH HOUSING
ELEMENT LAW.
LOCAL GOVERNMENTS MUST ADDRESS
ATD FINDINGS TO BECOME IN
COMPLIANCE.
IN EIGHTY YOU LAW FINDING SOME
COMPLAINTS WITH PROCESS.
DOES NOT EXIST.
AND THAT'S WILL RECAP ON THE
HISTORY OF EIGHTY YOU. FOR
COLLEAGUES ANY QUESTIONS.
WELL.
IS QUIRK.
SILVA ON THE EIGHTY YOU IT'S
WHEN YOU TALK ABOUT THE UNITS.
OF HOW HOW MUCH.
PARKING IS REQUIRED DOES THAT
MEAN THE UNIT OR THE BEDROOMS.
NO IT -- IN
FOR TWO THOUSAND SEVENTEEN HIM
AND THAT CHANGE FOR TWO THOUSAND
EIGHTEEN AND THE MAXIMUM NUMBER
OF PARKING PLACES FOR AN EIGHTY
YOU IS ONE PER UNIT.
OKAY SO IF YOU HAD STATE. TWO
SMALL BEDROOMS OR THREE YOU
STILL ONLY NEED TO HAVE ONE
THAT'S CORRECT UNLESS THERE'S AN
EXEMPTION.
FOR NINE SUCH AS IF THE AT YOU
IS WITHIN HALF A MILE OF PUBLIC
TRANSIT.
THEN YOU DON'T NEED TO HAVE ANY
THAT'S CORRECT.
THANK YOU YOU WALK.
BY THE QUESTIONS I HAVE ONE
QUICK WHAT.
IS THERE ANYTHING EXISTS
EXISTING LAW THAT REQUIRES
EIGHTY USED TO BE AFFORDABLE.
IN NO SHOULD REQUIRE THEM TO BE
AFFORDABLE NOT IN STATE LAW NO --
I BELIEVE I'VE SEEN ONE EIGHTY
YOU ORDINANCE THAT ALLOWED A
SIGNIFICANT REDUCTION IN FEES IF
THERE WAS A COMMITMENT FOR A
DEED RESTRICTION ON THE PROPERTY.
TO AND TO LOWER INCOME FOR A SET
PERIOD OF TIME.
THANK YOU YOU WALK.
ANY OTHER QUESTIONS.
MISTER NICHOLAS I KNOW YOU'RE
GOING TO BE SPEAKING LATER ON
THE PANEL BUT THE QUESTION I
HAVE FOR YOU YOU CAN ANSWER NOW
OR LATER IS.
DO YOU SEE GAPS IN THE LAW THAT
YOU THINK WE OUGHT TO BE
ADDRESSING I KNOW WE HAVE A
NUMBER OF COLLEAGUES THAT WILL
BE IT LIKELY PROPOSING.
WHAT LEGISLATION THIS TERRY BUT
JUST CURIOUS WHAT WHAT GENERAL
TOPICS YOU THINK WE OUGHT TO
FOCUS ON?
WHAT?
I DID GO THROUGH A FEW IN HERE
AND THIS IS PEOPLE OFF THAT
QUITE OFTEN AND THIS IS IF I HAD
TO PICK THREE AT THE TOP.
IT'S PARKING IT'S FEES AND IT
MIGHT BE OWN OCCUPANCY.
COULD YOU ELABORATE A LITTLE BIT
ON EACH OF THOSE TOPICS PARKING
THERE ARE MANY JURISDICTIONS
THAT BELIEVE THAT FOR INSTANCE A
GARAGE FOR THE PRIMARY DWELLING --
IS EXIT IS NOT ALLOWED BY THAT
JURISDICTION AND WHERE IT IS
ALLOWED OR REQUIRED TO BE
ALLOWED BY STATE LAW.
AND AND THEN THE REQUIRED
PARKING PLACES WE JURISDICTION
THAT MIGHT REQUIRE FOR PARKING
PLACES PER SINGLE FAMILY HOME --
BUT DO NOT WANT TO GIVE UP A AN
ENCLOSED PARKING STRUCTURE SUCH
AS A GARAGE AND ONE A
REPLACEMENT GARAGE --
THE OTHER IS IS DEFINITELY FEES
IS THAT THEY ARE NOT BEING PRO
RATED --
THAT -- EVEN
THOUGH THAT SECTION OF LAW HAS
BEEN IN THE FAX SINCE THE
NINETEEN EIGHTIES THE MEDICATION
IMPACT THE ACT.
I KNOW OUR SECOND PANEL IS GONNA
BE ON THIS TOPIC OF FEES BUT IT
COULD YOU ELABORATE ALSO IN YOUR
THIRD POINT.
THANK YOU ARE HURT OWNER
OCCUPIED UNITS.
THAT'S PROBABLY TAPERED OFF A
LITTLE BIT BUT THERE WERE A LOT
OF REQUIREMENTS WELL ACTUALLY
SEA SALT LAW ALLOWS A
JURISDICTION. TO REQUIRE THE
OWNER TO BE AN OCCUPANT OF THE
PROPERTY AND THERE WERE A LOT OF
CONCERNS THERE THE PEOPLE DIDN'T
RESIDE THERE ALL THE TIME OR IF
THEY WERE TO SELL THE PROPERTY.
THEY WOULD MOST LIKELY HAVE TO
FIND AN OWNER THAT WAS ALSO
WILLING TO BE A FULL TIME
RESIDENT TO THE PROPERTY --
AND THE SOME OF THE COVENANTS OR
DEED RESTRICTIONS THAT HAVE BEEN
CREATED BY THE LOCAL
JURISDICTIONS SAY IF.
THE PROPERTY OWNER DOES NOT
RESIDE IN THE SITE THE EIGHTY
YOU MUST BE REMOVED.
A REDUCTION OF HOUSING IT.
GREAT THANK YOU.
AND ONE MORE QUESTION MISS QUIRK
SILVA THE REVERSE OF WHAT --
ASSEMBLYMEMBER AGUIAR-CURRY SAID
SO -- THEY
DON'T HAVE TO BE AFFORDABLE BUT
ARE THERE INCENTIVES.
OUT OR AVAILABLE EITHER THROUGH
THE STATE OR LOCAL GOVERNMENT
THAT TO HAVE WORK TO GIVE
INCENTIVES FOR AFFORDABLE HUD'S.
DOESN'T LA HAVE.
NOT AT THE STATE LEVEL AT THIS
TIME -- IT
WOULD BE A TO LOOK IT WOULD BE
AT THE LOCAL LEVEL THE ONE IN
JURISDICTIONS THAT HAD THAT
PROVISION INCLUDED.
IN THEIR IN THEIR ADOPTED
ORDINANCE I DON'T KNOW OF OTHER
PROGRAMS BY LOCAL AGENCIES.
SITE I THOUGHT I HEARD EITHER
GLENDALE OR LOS ANGELES WAS
ACTUALLY GIVING THEM COMPLETELY
WRONG LIKE SEVENTY THOUSAND
DOLLARS TO HELP ENCOURAGE
BUILDING OF A UT A PILOT PROGRAM.
YES A PILOT PROGRAM THAT I
BELIEVE IT WAS SEVENTY FIVE
THOUSAND I'M NOT SURE ABOUT ALL
THE DETAILS OF IT BUT IT WAS
REQUIRED TO AGAIN I THINK IT'S
FOR PROVIDE.
HOUSING FOR HOMELESS FOR A SET
PERIOD OF TIME AND I THINK THE
THE THE HE WAS OR THE THE GRANT
WAS WAIVED AFTER.
AFTER THAT THAT AMOUNT OF TIME
FIVE YEARS HOUSING FOR HOMELESS.
AND I BELIEVE IT WAS IT WAS A
VERY LIMITED NUMBER OF OF THE
UNITS.
THANK YOU.
RIGHT.
AT THIS TIME THANK YOU FOR YOUR
TESTIMONY I'M GOING TO TURN IT
OVER TO MY FELLOW COACH FELL
CHAIR TO INTRODUCE EXPEL SO WE'D
LIKE -- TO
WELCOME THE THE PEOPLE THAT ON
THE SECOND POUND TO COME ON UP
WE HAVE THAMES.
TIM SUIT SU FOR FROM MBA
MANAGING DIRECTOR OF IN B. S..
WE HAVE DAVID GARCIA POLICY
DIRECTOR FROM TURNER CENTER OF
HOUSING INNOVATION AT THE
UNIVERSITY OF CALIFORNIA.
BERKELEY.
DAVID TOURING ASSISTANT CITY
MANAGER AND DIRECTOR OF PLANNING
AND ECONOMIC DEVELOPMENT FOR THE
CITY OF SANTA ROSA.
AND SOPHIA --
FINANCE EAST BAY MUNICIPAL
UTILITY DISTRICT.
WELCOME.
AND WE WILL KICK OFF A TIM
PLEASE.
THANK YOU FOR JOINING US TODAY
SURE [inaudible]
GOOD MORNING.
HI MY NAME IS TIM SIFFERT AND
I'M WITH THE FIRM OF NBS.
BEFORE I GET STARTED I WANT TO
MAKE TO COMPLETELY UNRELATED
DISCLOSURES IN THE IN THE CASE
OF TRANSPARENCY.
THE FIRST IS OUR FIRM WHICH BUT
WHICH BEEN AROUND FOR TWENTY
THREE YEARS WORKS ALMOST
EXCLUSIVELY FOR LOCAL GOVERNMENT.
SO WE ARE AT THAT WHAT I WOULD
CALL A SORT OF TECHNICIAN IN
TERMS OF FEES AND RATES AND
CHARGES THAT KIND OF THING.
AND THEN COMPLETELY SEPARATE
ABOUT FIVE YEARS AGO WE
INSTALLED AND EIGHTY YOU AND ARE
SINGLE FAMILY HOME IN SAN
FRANCISCO.
SO WE'VE HAD THAT FOR FIVE YEARS
IT'S BEEN A GOOD EXPERIENCE --
PROVIDING BOTH INCOME FOR US IN
A PLACE FOR AN OLDER COUPLE TO
LIVE A COUPLE BLOCKS AWAY FROM
THE GRAND KIDS.
SO WITH THOSE TWO DISCLOSURES
COME I'M GONNA GET INTO A LITTLE
DISCUSSION HERE ABOUT FEES AND
CHARGES AND SUCH.
SO THERE ARE MANY TYPES A LOCAL
GOVERNMENT FEES AS AS YOU ALL
ARE AWARE OF EVERYTHING FROM
PLAN CHECK BUILDING PERMITS.
DEVELOPMENT IMPACT FEES AND
WATER OR SINCE --
SEWER CONNECTION FEES.
THEY'RE ALL SUBJECT TO VARIOUS
RULES --
BOTH LOCAL AND STATEWIDE --
SUCH AS AB.
SIXTEEN HUNDRED AND ALSO THE
CONSTITUTIONAL AMENDMENTS THAT
WE HAVE TO LIVE WITH WHICH
YOU'RE PROPOSITIONS --
TWENTY SIX AND TWO EIGHTEEN IN
ADDITION SOME LOCAL AGENCIES
CHARGE ON GOING.
RATES FOR THINGS LIKE WATER AND
SEWER SERVICES.
AND THOSE MAY HAVE THE ABILITY
TO CAPTURE A CERTAIN AMOUNT OF
COST FOR INFRASTRUCTURE.
AND BY THE WAY WE WERE HAVING A
DISCUSSION THIS MORNING ABOUT
THE THAN THE NAME OF THIS --
DISCUSSION ABOUT PROVIDING FOR
EXTRA SERVICES I THINK WE ALSO
NEED TO ACKNOWLEDGE
INFRASTRUCTURE IS IS A IS A BIG
PIECE OF THAT.
AS WELL.
SO THERE'S ALWAYS A COST BASIS
FOR ANY OF THESE FEES OR RATES
THAT ARE CHARGED BY A BY LOCAL
GOVERNMENTS --
UNLIKE PENALTIES AND FINES WHICH
DO NOT HAVE TO BE COST BASED.
SO OFFERED FOR SIMPLICITY I'M
JUST GOING TO BREAK THIS DOWN
INTO INTO THREE COMPONENTS --
THERE'S THERE'S THIS COULD BE AN
ALL DAY DISCUSSION AND I WHEN WE
DON'T HAVE ALL DAY.
SO THERE ARE.
USER AND REGULATORY FEES.
THERE DEVELOPMENT IMPACT FEES.
AND THEN THERE ARE WHAT WE CALL
HOOK UP FEES CONNECTION FEES FOR
UTILITIES BUT THEY WERE DOES
HURT THAT THIRD GROUP IS REALLY
IN A WAY A SUBSET OF OF THE
SECOND GROUP OF DEVELOPING
IMPACT FEES AND SUBJECT TO A LOT
OF THE SAME.
SO THE RULES AND AND GENERALLY
ACCEPTED PRACTICES.
SO IN TERMS OF THAT CATEGORY ONE
USER AND REGULATORY FEES THERE
THEY REPRESENT COST RECOVERY
OPPORTUNITIES FOR LOCAL
GOVERNMENT --
THEY MAY NOT EXCEED THE
ESTIMATED AND REASONABLE COST
FOR PROVIDING THE SERVICES --
LOCAL AGENCIES SHOULD HAVE AN
EXPRESS SET OF POLICIES IN TERMS
OF HOW THEY WOULD LIKE --
TO REFLECT THE COMMUNITY NEEDS
AND GOALS IN TERMS OF COST
RECOVERY SOME MAY BE 100% SOME
MAY BE AT 50% FOR VARIOUS POLICY
GOALS --
USER FEES ARE VOLUNTARY AND
THEIR IMPOSE ON THE PAIR BASED
ON THAT PAYERS ACTIONS SUCH AS
TAKING A RECREATION CLASS OR
PULLING A BUILDING PERMIT.
NOT REGULATORY FEES --
OUR OUR INVOLUNTARY RIGHT BASED
ON IN AGENCIES ABILITY TO
REGULATE AND THOSE COULD BE
ALONG THE LINES OF LIKE ANNUAL
INSPECTIONS ON CERTAIN --
COMMERCIAL PROPERTIES FOR FIRE
RELATED --
REASONS.
SO THE SECOND GROUP IS THE
DEVELOPMENT IMPACT FEES WHICH
WERE WHICH WERE MENTIONED BY
GREG -- I'LL
JUST A LITTLE BIT EARLIER TWO
PEOPLE WHO ARE DEVELOPING LAND --
FOR OFF SITE CAPITAL
IMPROVEMENTS. TO THE SYSTEM
ITSELF RIGHT.
THERE ARE VARIATIONS ALL OVER
CALIFORNIA BASED ON LOCAL --
POLICIES AND AND CONDITIONS SOME
COMMUNITIES AS WE KNOW HAVE
EXTENSIVE DEVELOPMENT IMPACT
FEES THEY LITERALLY RANGE FROM
PARKS. TO CHILD CARE FACILITIES.
OTHERS HAVE A FEW OR NONE --
FOR MANY DECADES NOW THE GENERAL
MANTRA HAS BEEN THAT DEVELOPMENT
SHALL PAY ITS OWN WAY --
IF A LARGE DEVELOPMENT IS COMING
INTO A A A TOWN.
THERE IS THERE IS A NEXUS THERE
IN TERMS OF THE MORE DEVELOPMENT
WOULD CREATE A NEED FOR MORE
PARKS.
MORE ROADS GREATER CAPACITY IN
THEIR WATER AND SEWER SYSTEM
RIGHT. FOR EXAMPLE PARK IMPACT
FEES AND QUIMBY FEES ARE USED --
TO FINANCE BOTH LAND ACQUISITION
FOR AN NEW PARK LAND AS WELL AS
PUTTING IN INFRASTRUCTURE --
ON THOSE PARK LANDS AND WE WANT
TO KEEP THE RATIO OF PARKS TO
PEOPLE INTACT IF YOU WILL --
EXAMPLES THOUGH OF LOCAL CONTROL
WE CAN LOOK --
TO WHERE I LIVE THE CITY A SAN
FRANCISCO DOES NOT HAVE A CITY
WIDE PART IMPACT FEE.
BUT THE TOWN OF WINDSOR IN THE
NORTH BAY DOES.
THEY HAVE UP CITY WIDE ONE THAT
BOTH FUNDS PARK LAND ACQUISITION
AS WELL AS IMPROVEMENTS TO THOSE.
TO THOSE PARKS IT'S BASED ON AN
EXTENSIVE ANALYSIS OF
DEVELOPMENT AND A LOT OF ALGEBRA
TO DIVIDE OUT THE COSTS AND WHAT
HAVE YOU.
SO THE THIRD CATEGORY WHICH WE
CALL CONNECTION FEES SOMETIMES
ARE CALLED SYSTEM DEVELOPMENT
CHARGES.
AND THESE ARE AGAIN A KINDLE
DEVELOPMENT IMPACT FEES BUT THEY
ARE BASED MORE ON THE OFF SITE
CAPITAL COSTS FOR THE CURRENT
SYSTEM.
OR EXPANSION TO MEET ADDITIONAL
DO ALL [inaudible]
THEY OFFSET. TO SOME DEGREE
GENERAL RATE INCREASES FOR WATER
AND SEWER.
RIGHT YOU CAN EITHER GET IT UP
FRONT OR YOU CAN GET OVER TIME.
BUT IT'S IMPORTANT TO RECOGNIZE
OF FOUR FOUR THINGS WHEN IT
LOOKED WHEN WE'RE LOOKING AT
DEVELOPMENT IMPACT FEES ORCHID
FOR CONNECTION FEES.
IS THAT THEY MUST SHOW A NEXUS
OR CONNECTION.
WHAT IS THE FEE CHARGED FOR AND
WHAT DO YOU GET?
YOUR MUST DEMONSTRATE
PROPORTIONALITY AND THAT THE
COST WILL BE DOCUMENTED AND BE
PROPORTIONAL.
THEY NEED TO FOLLOW CERTAIN
PROCEDURES FOR ADOPTING AND
THERE'S A PROTEST PROCESS.
AND THEY MUST BE REASONABLE AND
SHOW THE RELATIONSHIP.
SO UNLIKE OFF SITE CAPITAL
PERMITS THERE ARE SITUATIONS
WHERE -- A
WATER UTILITY WILL ALSO CHARGE
SORT OF ON SITE CONNECTION FEES.
AND THE MOST TYPICAL ONE YOU SEE
IS -- IF
YOU'RE ADDING AN AD YOU ARE AN
ADDITIONAL UNIT THEY'LL CHARGE
I'M A METER FEE.
IN IN MANY COMMUNITIES THAT
METER FEE IS DRIVEN BY
CONSERVATION.
NOT NECESSARILY. TO YOU KNOW
KEEP OUT NEW UNITS IF YOU WELL --
THEY REALLY IN IN SOME
COMMUNITIES ESPECIALLY IN THE
MONTEREY AREA WATER IS SO DEAR
THAT THEY'VE HAD.
THESE ADDITIONAL METERS
REQUIREMENTS FOR MANY MANY YEARS.
SO IT TO GET A LITTLE MORE GO
VERY BRIEFLY INTO HOW A
CALCULATION CAN WORK FOR
CAPACITY FEE.
SO IN THEIR SIMPLEST FORM THESE
CAPACITY FEES OR A SYSTEM
DEVELOPMENT CHARGES ART ART MAR
MERELY CALCULATED BY DIVIDING
THE COSTS ALLOCATED TO FUTURE
DEVELOPMENT BY THE NUMBER OF
UNITS OF NEW DEVELOPMENT
ANTICIPATED.
OVER A CERTAIN TIME FRAME.
SO YOU CAN HAVE THE CASA PLAN
FUTURE FACILITIES IMPROVEMENTS.
AND THEN LOOK AT THE NUMBER OF
NEW UNITS.
SO -- THE
CAPACITY FEE REVENUES THEN
CANNOT BE USED FOR ANNUAL
OPERATIONS SO THEY CANNOT BE
USED FOR THE PROVISION OF WATER
SEWER THAT KIND OF THING.
BUT THEY REALLY --
ARE IMPORTANT THAT YOU DON'T
EXCEED --
THE ACTUAL COST OF COURSE.
SO THE METHODOLOGIES YOU CAN USE
ARE EITHER ONE THE FIRST ONE IS.
LOOKING AT THE VALUE OF THE
SYSTEM IN PLACE NOW OR WHAT'S
CALLED THE HISTORICAL OR BY IN
METHOD IF YOU WELL YOU'VE GOT A
SYSTEM.
AND YOU JUST DIVIDE THAT OUT.
THE OTHER OPTION IS TO LOOK AT
PLANNED INCREMENTAL GROWTH AND
INCREMENTAL UNITS WHETHER
THEY'RE NEW HOMES OR OR
HIGHRISES OR A OR A TO USE SO
YOU THAT'S CALLED THE
INCREMENTAL OR SYSTEM
DEVELOPMENT APPROACH.
AND THE LAST ONE IS A
COMBINATION OF THE TWO
APPROACHES AND YOU SYNTHESIZE
THE TWO TOGETHER --
THIS COMBINATION APPROACH
REQUIRES NEW CUSTOMERS TO PAY
BOTH THEIR FAIR SHARE OF
EXISTING.
SYSTEM ASSETS AS WELL AS THEIR
SH FUTURE CAPITAL IMPROVEMENTS
NEEDED TO PROVIDE THEM WITH
CAPACITY BASED ON THE FORECASTS
FOR THAT WATER SYSTEM.
AS A RESULT THE NEW CUSTOMERS
CONNECTING WOULD ENTER AS EQUAL
PARTICIPANTS.
AND WITH REGARD TO THEIR
FINANCIAL COMMITMENT AND OF
OBLIGATION SEATED HILLARY.
MANY LOCAL AGENCIES IN
CALIFORNIA IF NOT ALL RELY ON A
NATIONAL PUBLICATION BY THE
AMERICAN WATER WORKS ASSOCIATION.
CALLED MANUAL M..
ONE IT'S WIDELY AVAILABLE AND
IT'S PROBABLY ON THE BOOKSHELF
OF ALMOST EVERY --
PRACTITIONER IN THE WATER RATES --
WORLD OR OR SOME TEN GENTLE AREA.
SO THAT'S AN EXAMPLE OF HOW SOME
OF THESE FEES ARE CALCULATED
THEY ARE SUPPOSED TO BE
PROPORTIONAL BASED ON THEIR
TAXATION NO PUN INTENDED OF THE
SYSTEM.
THAT THEY'RE THAT THEY'RE BUYING
INTO OR OR CONNECTING UP --
TO ALL OF THESE FEES THAT I
MENTIONED REQUIRE A LOGICAL
ANALYTICAL APPROACH TO DETERMINE
THEIR COST BASIS.
THE LOOK THERE ARE LOCAL
VARIATIONS THROUGHOUT CALIFORNIA.
BUT THEY SHOULD GENERALLY
REFLECT --
GENERALLY EXPECT ACCEPTED PRINT --
THROUGHOUT YOU KNOW THROUGHOUT
THE STATE AS WELL AS THROUGHOUT
THE UNITED STATES.
SO THE QUESTIONS THAT I HAD THAT
I ASK MYSELF AS DOES DOES THE
ADDITION OF AN EIGHTY YEAR
REQUIRE A NEW CONNECTION OR
MAYBE IT'S JUST A MERELY A TIE
IN TO THE EXISTING LINE. TO THEY
MAIN AND NOT SUFFICIENT TO TAKE
CARE OF THE SINGLE FAMILY HOUSE
AND EIGHTY YOU OR DO THEY NEED
TO UP SIZE.
SO THOSE SORT OF GRANULAR
DECISIONS HAVE TO BE MADE --
ON A CASE BY CASE BASIS
SOMETIMES.
WILL A LARGER CONNECTION BE
REQUIRED FOR ADDITIONAL LIVING
AREA IS A METER REQUIRED FOR ANY
UNIT OR EIGHTY YOU.
WILL AND EIGHTY YOU GENERATE
ADDITIONAL DEMAND FOR PARKS AND
SCHOOL FACILITIES.
AND IF SO.
WHO WILL PAY FOR THAT AND HOW
WOULD THOSE BE PAID?
FOR I'M THE TAKE AWAY THAT I DID
WANT YOU TO TO LEAVE WITH A
KNOWS A LOT OF INFORMATION SHORT
PERIOD OF TIME.
IS THAT --
THE FEES ARE SHOULD BE COST
BASED -- IN
THE IN THEIR CALCULATION AND
THEY SHOULD ALWAYS FOLLOW
GENERALLY ACCEPTED METHODOLOGIES.
USING -- THE
LOCAL COSTS AND ASSUMPTIONS.
SO THAT IS MY VERY QUICK
TREATISE OF A TOPIC THAT WE
USUALLY HAVE HOURS FOR SELF.
I'M HAPPY TO ANSWER ANY
QUESTIONS.
THE DO IT DOES ANYBODY HAVE ANY
QUESTIONS TO HIM.
I HAVE ONE THIS COMES OUT --
ARE THERE DIFFERENCES HOW A CITY --
WILL SET RATES VERSUS A SPECIAL
DISTRICT.
THAT'S A GOOD QUESTION I WAS
REVIEWING --
GREG NECKLACES --
A MEMO THAT HE JUST HANDED ME A
LITTLE BIT AGO THAT IN THEORY
THERE SHOULD NOT BE ANY
DIFFERENCE BETWEEN A CITY EN
ESPECIAL DISTRICT.
BUT THERE ARE OFTEN DIFFERENCES
AND IN PRACTICE BECAUSE OF THE
ABILITY OF OF CONTROL AND LAND
USE.
AND THAT KIND OF THING BUT IN
THEORY A CITY IN A SPECIAL
DISTRICT SHOULD BE PROVIDING THE
SAME.
LEVEL OF SERVICE BUT A SPECIAL
DIS CANNOT CHARGE AN IMPACT FEE.
IF THE CITY DOES NOT WANT TO
COOPERATE AND WE SEE THAT OFTEN
WITH.
WE SHOULD UP WITH FIRE DISTRICTS
BUT IT CERTAINLY COULD BE.
THE SAME WITH A A WATER DISTRICT
FOR EXAMPLE [inaudible]
THANK YOU.
OKAY OUR NEXT SPEAKER WILL BE --
DAVID GARCIA.
FROM DAVID.
GOOD MORNING AND THANK YOU FOR
HAVING ME THIS MORNING MY NAME
IS DAVID GARCIA I'M THE POLICY
DIRECTOR AT THE UC BERKELEY
TURNER CENTER FOR HOUSING
INNOVATION AND I'VE BEEN ASKED --
TO JOIN THIS HEARING THIS
MORNING TO DISCUSS SPECIFICALLY
WHAT WE KNOW FROM OUR RESEARCH
ON EIGHTY USE WITH REGARDS TO
FEES AND WE ALL KNOW THAT EIGHTY
USE ARE WELL POSITIONED TO PLAY
A SIGNIFICANT PART IN
ALLEVIATING THE STATE'S HOUSING
DEFICIT.
THEY ARE INHERENTLYLESS
EXPENSIVE TO BUILD THE ARE
DRIVEN BY INDIVIDUAL HOMEOWNERS
AND THEY FIT NEATLY INTO OUR
EXISTING LAND USE PATTERNS AND
TO THAT LAST POINT.
OF THE TURNER CENTER ACTUALLY
RECENTLY RE RELEASED THE RESULTS
OF A YEARLONG STATEWIDE SURVEY
THAT EXAMINED VARIOUS LAND USE
PRACTICES AND POLICIES
THROUGHOUT CALIFORNIA.
AND ONE OF THE MAIN TAKEAWAYS
FROM THAT SURVEY IS THAT ABOUT
70% OF LAND IN CALIFORNIA IS
OWNED EXCLUSIVELY FOR SINGLE
FAMILY HOMES.
AND SO THANKS TO RECENT REFORMS
TO EIGHTY USE WE ACTUALLY HAVE A
TREMENDOUS OPPORTUNITY TO CREATE
SIGNIFICANT AMOUNTS OF NEW
HOUSING IN THESE AREAS WITHOUT
OPENING UP A SINGLE ACRE OF NEW
LAND. TO DEVELOPMENT --
SO SO AGAIN I WAS AS WE HAVE
DONE AND WHAT WE CAN TELL WITH
REGARDS TO FEES AND SO I
APPROACH THIS QUESTION IN TWO
WAYS THE FIRST IS.
WHAT DO WE KNOW ABOUT WHAT
CITIES ARE CHARGING --
HOMEOWNERS TO CREATE EIGHTY USE
AND FROM THERE WHAT ARE THE
IMPLICATIONS OF THESE FEES IN
OUR ABILITY TO BUILD THE
STRUCTURES IN CALIFORNIA.
AND SO TO THE FIRST QUESTION WE
ACTUALLY DO HAVE SOME
INFORMATION ON WHAT'S USER
CHARGING AND WE DO KNOW THAT IT
DOES VERY GREATLY DEPENDING ON
THE CITY AND COUNTY THAT.
YOU ARE IN --
THE SURVEY THAT I MENTIONED
EARLIER --
INCLUDES A WHOLE SECTION ON
EIGHTY YOU POLICIES AND
PRACTICES INCLUDING A QUESTION
ON WHAT LOCALITIES ARE CHARGING
HOMEOWNERS.
FOR CALM EXCUSE ME FOR EIGHTY
USE.
AND FROM THE RESPONSES WE
RECEIVED FROM THIS QUESTION WE
KNOW THAT THE MEAN.
AMOUNTS CHARGE PER UNIT FOR AN
EIGHTY YOU IN CALIFORNIA IS
EIGHT THOUSAND SEVEN HUNDRED
DOLLARS.
AND EIGHT THOUSAND SEVEN HUNDRED
AND FURTHERMORE WE KNOW THAT
ABOUT A QUARTER OF OUR
RESPONDENTS NOTED THAT THEY
CHARGE MORE THAN FIFTEEN
THOUSAND DOLLARS.
PER EIGHTY YOU WE ALSO --
WE ALSO SAW A FEW EXAMPLES OF
CITIES REPORTING THAT THEY
CHARGE UPWARDS OF FORTY THOUSAND
DOLLARS PER UNIT AND SOME CLOSE
TO FIFTY THOUSAND DOLLARS.
SO IT'S IMPORTANT TO NOTE THAT
THE NUMBERS THAT WE HAVE IN OUR
SURVEY REFLECT ONLY RESPONSES
FROM CITIES AND COUNTIES AND
WHAT THEY CHARGE.
AND SO ANY CHARGES THAT ARE LEVY
SIX OR TO THE DISTRICTS FOR
SCHOOL DISTRICTS THOSE ARE NOT
REFLECTED IN THE NUMBERS THAT WE
SAW IN THE SURVEY.
AND AS A RESULT --
HOMEOWNER WHO IS GOING TO THE
EIGHTY PROCESS NOW IS ALMOST
CERTAINLY EXPERIENCING HIGHER
FEES WILL WE HAVE REPORTED.
ANOTHER INTERESTING TAKE AWAY
FROM OUR SURVEY IS THAT THE
QUESTION REGARDING WHAT
LOCALITIES ARE CHARGING FOR USE.
WAS BY FAR THE HAD THE LOWEST
RESPONSE RATE OF ANY QUESTIONS
IN THE EIGHTY YOU SECTION ONLY
ABOUT 50% OF RESPONDENTS CHOSE
TO PROVIDE INFORMATION FOR THAT
QUESTION WHICH PERHAPS TELLS US
THE CITY'S DON'T NECESSARILY
HAVE A A GOOD FEEL. FOR WHAT
THEY'RE CHARGING FOR THE
SPECIFIC TYPE OF DEVELOPMENT AND
THEREFORE THEY ARE NOT ABLE TO
ANSWER THE QUESTION ON OUR
SURVEY.
AND THIS IS AN IMPORTANT
QUESTION TO UNDERSTAND BECAUSE
WE DO KNOW THAT --
FEES CAN MANY TIMES BE A
SIGNIFICANT BARRIER TO A
HOMEOWNER LOOKING TO BUILD A
UNIT IN THEIR BACKYARD.
AGAIN AT USE OUR INHERENTLY LESS
EXPENSIVE TO BUILD HOWEVER IF
THEY ARE SUBJECT TO SIMILAR FEES
THAT'S SAY A SINGLE FAMILY HOME
OR AN APARTMENT UNIT MAY BE
SUBJECT.
TO THAN A DISPROPORTIONATE SHARE
OF THAT PROJECTS BUDGET IS GOING
TO GO GOING TO DEVICES
HOMEOWNERS FROM PURSUING --
THE CONSTRUCTION OF AN EIGHTY
YOU.
KNOW WE HAVE PLENTY OF EVIDENCE
THAT SHOWS THAT IN PLACES WHERE
EIGHTY YOU FEES HAVE BEEN WAIVED
OR LOWERED.
THAT A INCREASE IN APPLICATIONS
AND CONSTRUCTION PERMITS SOON
FOLLOWS A FOR EXAMPLE IN THE
CITY OF PORTLAND. TWENTY TEN
THAT CITY RECOGNIZE THIS
IMBALANCE AND DECIDED TO WAIVE
THEIR EIGHTY YOU FEES AND IN SUB
SCHOOL YEARS SAW --
OF SIGNIFICANT INCREASE IN THE
AMOUNT OF EIGHTY USE THEIR TO
THE POINT WHERE IN.
TWENTY SIXTEEN THE CITY OF
PORTLAND ISSUED MORE PERMITS FOR
EIGHTY USE THAN SINGLE FAMILY
HOMES IN THAT CITY.
WE HAVE EXAMPLES OF THIS IN
CALIFORNIA AS WELL FOR EXAMPLE
SANTA CRUZ IN --
TWENTY FOURTEEN IN ADDITION TO
SEVERAL OTHER EIGHTY REFORMS ARE
THEY LOWER THEIR FEES AND HAVE
SINCE SEEN AN INCREASING USE
THAT COMMUNITY AS WELL.
MORE RECENTLY THE CITY OF SAN
DIEGO.
LAST SPRING SIGNIFICANTLY
REDUCED THEIR IMPACT FEES FOR
YOU TO USE A GOING FROM --
BETWEEN 240-002-29000RADIO DOWN
280-002-13000 DOLLARS PREVIEW.
AND STAFF THEIR NOTES THAT SINCE
HIS REFORM WAS ENACTED EIGHTY
YOU APPLICATIONS HAVE INCREASED
SO THESE THESE ARE JUST TWO
EXAMPLES --
I THINK WE WILL HEAR ABOUT A FEW
MORE -- OF
CITIES ACROSS THE STATE THAT
HAVE RECOGNIZE THE NEED TO
BALANCE THE NEED FOR MORE
HOUSING WITH THE AMOUNT OF FEES
THEY CHARGE FOR EIGHTY USE SO.
AGAIN WE KNOW THAT FEES ARE
OFTEN TIMES CITED BY HOMEOWNERS
AS A SIGNIFICANT BARRIER --
FOR WHETHER OR NOT THEY WILL
DECIDE TO BE.
AND IN PLACES WHERE WE SEE
DECREASES OR WAIVERS FOR FEES WE
DO SEE AN INCREASE IN PRODUCTION
OF THOSE PLACES SO --
I'LL LEAVE IT AT THAT AND THANK
YOU AGAIN FOR TAKING TIME TO
EXAMINE THIS TOPIC AND I LOOK
FORWARD TO FURTHER DISCUSSION.
SO AMERICA EXCELLENT.
ON THE EITHER COUNTIES OR CITIES
THAT LOWERED THEIR FEES WAS THAT
A COUNTY OR A CITY DECISION --
SO.
THE SURVEY REFLECTS RESPONSES
FROM EITHER A CITY OR COUNTY OR
IN INSTANCES WHERE THE CITY IS
THE COUNTY --
AND SO IN IN THOSE INSTANCES IT
WOULD BE CITIES REPORTING THEIR
OWN FEES THAT THEY CHARGE FOR A
TO USE AND SO TO THE EXTENT THAT
THEY HAVE DECIDED TO LOWER THOSE
FEES THAT WOULD BE --
FOR THE FEES THOSE CITY
SPECIFICALLY CHARGED THERE MAY
BE OTHER FEES AT THE COUNTY
CHARGES OR PERHAPS --
OTHER DISTRICTS CHARGE THAT THE
CITY DOESN'T NECESSARILY HAVE
CONTROL OVER THAT THOSE HE'S MAY
STILL EXIST [inaudible]
THANK YOU.
ASSEMBLYMEMBER GLORIA.
MISTER SEE FOR YOUR YOUR
COMMENTS IN FOR KNOWLEDGE IN THE
CITY SAN DIEGO AND THE WORK THAT
THEY'RE DOING TO THEM TO TO LEAD
ON THIS ISSUE WELL IN TERMS OF
THE NUMBERS YOU ARE GIVING US
THE 800-025-0000.
RANGE OBVIOUSLY QUITE FAR THAT'S
ON THAT CITY AND COUNTY FEES
WHAT ABOUT --
ANY OTHER --
REVIEW OR AM I THINKING PUTTING
THE FROM MY DISTRICT THE COASTAL
COMMISSION PLAYS A PRETTY
SIGNIFICANT ROLE IN THIS --
ONE OF THOSE FEES LOOK LIKE IF
ANY IS THERE ANYONE WORK ON THAT
PARTICULAR ISSUE --
THAT'S A EXCELLENT QUESTION AND
I WOULD SAY THAT --
OUR SURVEY CAPTURED ONLY --
CITIES AND COUNTIES SO AGAIN --
ANY OTHER --
ENTITY THAT HAS THE AUTHORITY TO
LEVY FEES --
THEY WERE NOT INCLUDED ARE
SERVING AS A RESULT I'M NOT ONLY
ARE HOMEOWNER SUBJECT TO THE
FEES THAT CITIES ARE CHARGING
BUT THERE ARE A WHOLE HOST OF
OTHER ENTITIES THAT MAY BE
CHARGING FEES ON TOP OF WHAT
CITIES DOING AS WELL.
MINDFUL IT HAS TO BE WHAT PEOPLE
WANT TO BE RIGHT SO --
MAYBE NAY FOR FOR FOR FOLLOW UP
CERTAINTY.
JUST TO FOLLOW UP ON THAT I
REMEMBER LAST YEAR AND SOME
DISCUSSION AROUND HUSING FEES
THERE WAS SOME TESTIMONY THAT
THERE ARE JURISDICTIONS AROUND
THE STATE THAT HAD.
COLLECTED FEES TO BE SIX FIGURES
1-001-005-0000 DOLLARS.
JUST FOR THE FEES NOT FOR
CONSTRUCTION DOES AT JIVE WITH
YOUR ANECDOTAL UNDERSTANDING OF
THIS.
YEAH I I I HAVE SEEN ANECDOTAL
EVIDENCE THAT'S IN CERTAIN.
LOCALITIES IN CERTAIN
CIRCUMSTANCES FEES CAN AND
COMPRISE PERHAPS EVEN 50% OF THE
WHOLE COST TO DEVELOPING EIGHTY
DEPENDING ON THE TYPE.
OF EIGHTY YOU --
THAT HOMEOWNER IS PRETTY THIS
THIS IS AN ISSUE THAT PERHAPS
GOES BEYOND A EIGHTY USE IN THAT
SAID THE AUTHORITY THAT IS
GRANTED TO CITIES TO SET THEIR
FEES ACTUALLY QUITE BROAD.
WHICH ACCOUNTS FOR THE VARIATION
THAT YOU HAVE ACROSS THE STATE
WHERE YOU HAVE SOME CITIES THAT
THEY HAVE THESE ARE QUITE LOW
WHERE YOU WHERE YOU HAVE OTHER.
CITIES THAT HAVE FEES THAT ARE
COMPATIBLE MUCH HIGHER.
IN I KNOW A FEW YEARS AGO --
ONE OF OUR COLLEAGUES -
MISTER GRAYSON FROM THE CITY
CONCORD AT PASSED A LAW
REQUIRING A LOOK AT ALL FEES
ACROSS ALL JURISDICTIONS IN MY
HOPE IS IN THE COMING MONTHS
WE'RE GOING TO HAVE THAT.
VERY GRANULAR INFORMATION BUT
ONE OF THE THINGS I THINK I
HEARD FROM YOU WAS AT HALF THE
CITY'S DID NOT RESPOND TO YOUR
QUESTION ON WHAT THE FEES WERE
SO IT IS VERY POSSIBLE.
THAT THERE CITIES CHARGING VERY
SIGNIFICANT FEES AND YOU JUST
DON'T KNOW THAT BECAUSE YOU
DON'T HAVE THAT DATA.
I THINK THAT'S THE AFFAIRS
OPTION THIS OKAY THANK YOU.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH MR GARCIA --
PRECIADO TESTIMONY IN WILL MOVE
ON TO DAVID CONE --
IN I THINK IT PRINTS OUT RIGHT
WELCOME AND I'M ANXIOUS TO HEAR
YOUR COMMENTS TODAY SINCE THE
FIRES RAVAGED A YOUR AREA SO
THANK YOU VERY MUCH FOR
ATTENDING TODAY.
THANK YOU THANK YOU CHAIR THANK
YOU FOR HAVING ME HERE TODAY
SANTA ROSA AND SO WE WE WE ARE
POPULATION AS PER PERSPECTIVE
ABOUT A HUNDRED EIGHTY THOUSAND
PEOPLE --
FIFTH LARGEST CITY IN THE BAY
AREA.
AND WE ARE AS MANY CITIES IN
CALIFORNIA HAS HOUSING SHORTAGE --
AFTER THE FIRES WE TURN IT
BECAME EXASPERATED TO A POINT
WHERE WE HAD A CRISIS ON OUR
HANDS SO WE TOOK A VERY
AGGRESSIVE APPROACH TO HOUSING.
ACROSS THE BOARD AND EIGHTY USE
BEING ONE OF THOSE TOOLS WE PUT
INTO PLACE AND SO WHAT I WOULD
SAY IS THAT THE THE ELEMENTS
THAT WERE PUT INTO PLACE IN
TWENTY SEVENTEEN BY THE THE
STATE --
HELP GIVE US THE PLATFORM.
TO LAUNCH AND JUMP INTO THIS
THIS WORLD A LOT QUICKER --
SO THE POLICY THAT DEALT WITH
PARKING --
AND OTHER THINGS THAT THE STATE
PUT IN PLACE --
WE THEN TOOK THAT INFORMATION
WENT OUT TO OUR PUBLIC DID
PUBLIC MEETINGS HAD AN ENORMOUS
RESPONSE FROM OUR PUBLIC HUNT
HUNDREDS OF PEOPLE SHOW UP TO
THE PUBLIC MEETINGS.
TO TALK ABOUT WHAT ARE THE
BARRIERS LOCALLY TO BUILDING
EIGHTY USE AND CAME UP WITH
THREE THINGS PARKING SETBACKS
AND COST THE COST INCLUDING FEES
BUT ALSO CONSTRUCTION AND TIME
TO GET THIS GIG EIGHTIES BUILT.
US WHAT WE DID IS --
BROUGHT ALL THOSE --
THOSE COMMENTS TOGETHER I'M JUST
LIKE WE AS WE MADE AT LOCAL YOU
TO FIGURE OUT HOW WE CAN MY
VISIT AND HE PUT IN PLACE
[inaudible]
PUT MORE.
AND SO WHAT WE DID IS --
DRESSED FEES --
AND WE WE WENT THROUGH AND
DETERMINE ANYTHING SEVEN FIFTY
FIVE SQUARE FEET OR LESS WE WERE
GONNA REDUCE THE FEES
DRAMATICALLY SO YOU JUST HEARD
OUR FEES WERE IN THAT TWENTY
TWENTY FIVE THOUSAND DOLLAR
RANGE. FOR EIGHTY YOU --
THEY NOW ARE AT SEVEN FIFTY FOUR
THOUSAND DOLLARS SO THEY WENT
FROM TWENTY TWENTY TWO THOUSAND
DOLLARS TO FOUR THOUSAND DOLLARS --
THERE IS A GRAPHIC BELIEVE THAT
WAS IN YOUR PACKET THAT WE PUT
TOGETHER TO SHOW THE IMPACT OF
WHAT THOSE FEES WERE WE WERE
SEEN BETWEEN. THREE TO EIGHT
EIGHTY YOU APPLICATIONS A YEAR
AFTER THE STATE LAW INTO EFFECT
THAT ADDRESS PARKING AND
SETBACKS --
WE SAW A SLIGHT INCREASE ONCE WE
REDUCE THE FEES WE SAW FAIRLY
DRAMATIC INCREASE OR UP TO EIGHT
HUNDRED EIGHTEEN EIGHTY USE THIS
YEAR ARE BACK IN.
TWENTY EIGHTEEN AND WE EXPECT
THAT TO RISE AGAIN NEXT YEAR.
OF THE OTHER INTERESTING ASPECT
OF THIS IS WE PUT THIS POLICY
THE PLACE VERY QUICKLY AFTER THE
FIRE TO TRY TO ADDRESS THE
REBUILD.
AND WE WORKED WITH DEVELOPERS
SHOWED ON THE POLICY PUT THESE --
PROGRAMS IN PLACE AND DIVERT AND
AS PEOPLE ARE REBUILDING THEIR
HOMES ARE LOOKING AT ADDING
EIGHTY USED TO THEIR REBUILD SO
THE PREMIUM ABOVE THE GARAGE.
DIRECTION INCREASING HOUSING
STOCK WITH THE REBUILD SO JUST
THIS GRAPH SHOWS THAT IN TWENTY
EIGHTEEN WE ADDED THIRTY NEW
UNITS WE WOULD HAVE HAD --
AT AS PART OF THE REBUILD
BECAUSE OF THE THE OTHER WE DID
A DRY EARLIER IN THE CON ABILITY
COUNSEL DIDN'T IT WAS IT WAS
INPUT FROM OUR COMMUNITY --
THAT WE DO HAVE EITHER YOU
EITHER YOU HAVE TO LIVE IN ONE
OF THE UNITS IF YOU DON'T LIVE
IN ONE OF THE UNITS YOU HAVE TO
HAVE AN AFFORDABILITY CONTRACT --
THROUGH OUR HOUSING AUTHORITY A
SO THAT WAS THE TRADE OFF TO SAY
WE'RE WE'RE GONNA PROVIDE AN
INCENTIVE BUT WE WANT TO TRY TO
GET SOMETHING FOR OUR COMMITTEE
WHICH IS OF AFFORDABLE HOUSING
THAT WEEKS WE DESPERATELY NEED --
SO THAT'S AN ADDITIONAL
LOCALIZED THING WE PUT ON TO IT.
ON THE SECOND THING THAT ARE THE
THIRD THING WE'RE TRYING WE'RE
GONNA BE ADDRESSING THIS PROCESS.
SO WHAT WE'VE LEARNED IN THE
REBUILD IS THAT WE CAN TERM
PLANS AROUND VERY QUICKLY WE CAN
DO PRE APPROVAL PLANS --
WITH RIGHT NOW WE'RE APPROVING
PLANS AND FIVE DAYS FOR REBUILD --
IN IN A LOT OF THAT HAS TO DO
WITH -- COME
UP WITH US FOR MASTER PLAN FOR
PLANS OF WHAT THESE UNITS LOOK
LIKE PRE PROVEN THAT WE CAN
APPROVING OVER THE COUNTER
SERENA TAKE THAT.
KNOWLEDGE THAT WE LEARNED FOR
THE REBUILD PROCESS APPLY THAT
TO EIGHTY USE TO TURN THOSE
AROUND QUICKER SO WE'RE TRYING
TO ADDRESS IT FROM MULTIPLE
FRONTS WAS ON THE FEES.
THE PROCESS AND BUT STILL TRY TO
HAVE ADDRESSED AFFORDABILITY
ELEMENT TO IT SO THAT'S
ESSENTIALLY HOW WERE WERE
ADDRESSING EIGHTY USE AND AND
AGAIN WE'VE SEEN IT FAIRLY GOOD
RESPONSE.
ON THE ONLY THING I WOULD ADD TO
THE PREVIOUS CONVERSATION IS
THAT --
SOMEBODY OUTSIDE AGENCIES YOU
TALKED ABOUT THE SCHOOL.
BECAUSE THEY HAVE FOR THEIR
TEACHERS AND STAFF THAT THEY
HAVE ASKED ME TO COME PRESENT TO
THE SCHOOL BOARD BECAUSE THEY
WANT TO LOOK AT WHAT WE'VE DONE
IN TO SEE IF THEY CAN MODEL
SOMETHING OFF OF WHAT WE DID
LOCALLY TO APPLY TO THEIR SCHOOL
DISTRICT FEES SO --
THEY'RE STARTING THERE'S OTHER
PLAYERS ARE STARTING TO GET
INVOLVED IN THIS CONVERSATION I
THINK THAT'S GOOD FOR EVERYBODY
AS WE MOVE FORWARD.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH ARE THERE
ANY QUESTIONS. ONE QUESTION I I
THINK THAT'S A GREAT STORY.
OUR HOUSING COMMITTEE WERE
LOOKING AT POTENTIALLY HOLDING A
FUTURE HEARING ABOUT WHAT
REBUILDING AFTER WILDFIRES LOOKS
LIKE SO WE MAY BE IN TOUCH WITH
YOU ON THAT --
TELL US WHAT YOUR COST RECOVERY
LOOKS LIKE IF YOU AREN'T RECOUP
IN A FEES HOW ARE YOU ABLE.
HOW MUCH OF YOUR COSTS ARE YOU
ACTUALLY GETTING BACK HOW YOU
PAY FOR INFRASTRUCTURE?
RATE SAYS YOU HEARD THAT TO TWO
DIFFERENT FEES ONE IS THE
PERMITTING FEE AND ONE IS THE
IMPACT FEES THE FEES WE REDUCE
FOR THE IMPACT FEES WHICH WAS
THE BIG DOLLAR AMOUNT --
IS ESSENTIALLY WHAT WHAT HAPPENS
IS YOU CAN HAVE A HOME AND YOU
CAN DO A THREE HUNDRED SQUARE
FOOT ADDITION TO YOUR HOME.
AND PEOPLE TO LIVE IN THAT HOME
SO WE TOOK THE APPROACH THAT IF
IT'S A SMALLER UNIT --
THAT THAT PRIMARY RESIDENCE PAID
THAT IMPACT FEE THEY PAID THE
FULL IMPACT VIEW OF THAT
ORIGINAL HOUSE SO THAT IMPACT IS
BEING ADDRESSED --
BY ADDING A FEW MORE PEOPLE TO
SAY TO PEOPLE WITHIN A SQUARE
FOOT -- UNIT
THAT IMPACT IS INSIGNIFICANT IN
THE SKIN THE SCHEME OF THE
OVERALL SYSTEM AND SO THAT'S THE
APPROACH WE TOOK AGAIN WE WERE
FAIRLY AGGRESSIVE ON IT --
WE HAD TO MAKE THAT CALL --
BUT ANY UP TO TWELVE HUNDRED PER
STATE LAW --
BUT ANYTHING OVER A HUNDRED
SQUARE FEET WE INCREMENTALLY
STEPPED UP THE FEE TO TRY TO
ACCOMMODATE THAT ADDITIONAL
IMPACT TO THE SYSTEM AS YOU
HEARD EARLIER.
SO IT BETWEEN SEVEN OR FIFTY TO
A THOUSAND IT'S 25% OF THE
ANYTHING. THOUSAND OF TWELVE
HUNDRED WE DID 50% FEE.
AGAIN THAT WAS TO TRY TO RECOUP
SOME OF THOSE COSTS TO THE TO
YOUR POINT TO MAKE SURE THAT
WE'RE NOT.
PUSHING ASIDE THE NEEDED
IMPROVEMENTS FOR PARKS AND ROADS
AND IT CAN ACTIVITY THAT WE NEED
OUR COMMUNITY.
ANYONE ELSE HAVE ANY QUESTIONS.
I HAVE A FEW.
I WANNA THANK YOU --
IF YOU ONLY KNEW WHAT HE'S BEEN
THROUGH.
AND HOW THEY'VE GOTTEN THIS A
COMMUNITY BACK ON THEIR FEET
SLOWLY BUT SURELY SO THANK YOU
FOR ALL YOUR HARD WORK AND TIME
AND FRUSTRATION.
I UNDERSTAND THAT --
SO COUPLE QUESTIONS I HAVE DO
YOU THINK THAT EVERY
JURISDICTION CAN DO THIS AS
ORDERED AS A DEPEND ON WHETHER
WATER SEWER IS DONE IN HOUSE.
OR RATHER THAN PROVIDED BY
SPECIAL DISTRICT IT'S A GREAT
QUESTION WE WE WE DO HAVE WATERS
OR IN HOUSE IN THE CITY --
WE THAT WAS ONE OF THE BIG AS WE
ACTUALLY IMPLEMENTED THIS FEE
STRUCTURE --
WITH JUST PARK AND AND OUR
CAPITAL FACILITY FEES WHICH IS
OUR INFRASTRUCTURE.
IT TOOK US ABOUT TWO MONTHS MORE
TO WORK WITH THE WATER
DEPARTMENT TO FIND A SOLUTION
THAT WOULD WORK FOR THEM AS YOU
HEARD THERE'S PROP TWO EIGHTEEN
AND OTHER ELEMENTS THAT WE HAD
TO BE AWARE OF OUR BE BE
CONCERNED ABOUT --
BUT WE FINALLY GOT THERE FOUND A
SOLUTION THAT WE THOUGHT WOULD
WORK SO WE DID --
LOOK AT THE SMALLER UNITS
ANYTHING OVER SEVEN FIFTY SQUARE
FEET THOSE WATERS OR IF YOU
START TO KICK AND THE OTHER
THING WE WORKED WITH HIM ON IS
THAT THE SMALLER UNITS WE DON'T%
REQUIRE SEPARATE CONNECTION.
A SEPARATE METER AGAIN THAT WAS
AN ADDED COST TO HOMEOWNERS
WHICH IS FAIRLY SUBSTANTIAL
ALMOST DOUBLES THE FEE SO WHEN
YOU GET INTO THE ROADWAY AND
START PUTTING IN INFRASTRUCTURE
IN METERS.
THAT IT ISN'T A BIG COST BUT
THERE IS A DISCUSSION TO HAVE
BECAUSE THERE'S A BIG PUSH FOR
WATER CONSERVATION AND SEPARATE
MEETING IN THERE'S A VALUE TO
THAT.
BUT OUR PRIORITY FOR OUR CITY
WAS BRINGING HOUSING STOCK TO
OUR COMMUNITY AND QUICKLY.
WE'VE DONE A GOOD JOB TRYING TO
DO THAT AND WHAT PROCESS WOULD
YOU RECOMMEND TO OTHER
JURISDICTIONS THEY'RE LOOKING --
TO EXPEDIA AT THE EIGHTY YOU.
CONSTRUCTION WITHIN THEIR
BOUNDARIES.
I KNOW YOU'VE HAD CHALLENGES AND
HE WAS SOME IDEAS.
I THINK THE ONE IS TO TO REACH
OUT TO COMMUNITY FIRST BECAUSE
IT DOES TAKE COMMUNITY INPUT --
SETBACKS AND PARKING OR ARE VERY
REAL THINGS TO INDIVIDUALS IN
THEIR HOMES.
PEOPLE PUSH BACK ON IF AS A
REDUCE PARKING MORE PARKING ON
THE STREET THAT THAT BECOMES A A
TOPIC -- BUT
I THINK THERE'S THERE'S AN A
PEOPLE EMBRACE THE CONCEPT OF
PROVIDING THIS --
FOR RIGHT REASONS I THINK WHAT
WE RECOMMEND IS --
OF DO LOOK AT THE FEE STRUCTURE --
IT YET YEAH I THINK I THINK BE
BOLD TRY THINGS IF IT DOESN'T
WORK FIX IT AND I THINK THAT'S
OUR AND HAS BEEN OUR MODEL
THROUGH THE ENTIRE REBUILD WE
DON'T THERE'S NO PLAYBOOK FOR
THIS WE'RE WE'RE TRYING TO
FIGURE HIS OUT AS WE GO WE WERE
TRYING.
THINGS IF IT DOESN'T WORK WE
TWEAK IT AND THEY'RE BACK TO
COUNCIL WE TWEAK IT AND WE KEEP
CHANGING IT.
UNTIL WE GET IT RIGHT BUT IF WE
JUST STOP AND WAIT UNTIL WE GET
SOMETHING PERFECT NOTHING WILL
HAPPEN AND I DON'T THINK
ANYTHING WILL MOVE FORWARD SO.
MY MY ADVICE TO JUMP IN AND AND
TRY SOMETHING AMEN [inaudible]
THE YEAH IT ARE THERE ANY OTHER
QUESTIONS.
OKAY SIGNAL MOVE ON TO OUR NEXT
SPEAKER GOOD MORNING MORNING --
WE HAVE SOPHIA'S SKODA FROM THE
DIRECTOR OF FINANCE FROM EAST
BAY MUNICIPAL UTILITY DISTRICT
ALSO EFFECTUALLY NOTICE.
IS FAMOUS.
THANK YOU AND GOOD MORNING
TERRACE AND A MEMBERS --
SO AGAIN YES I'M SO FEWEST GO TO
THE DIRECTOR OF FINANCE AT THE
EAST BAY MUNICIPAL UTILITY
DISTRICT AND I I AND WE VERY
MUCH APPRECIATE THIS OPPORTUNITY
TO SHARE EAST BAY MEDS.
PERSPECTIVE ON UTILITY AT
CONNECTION CAPACITY FEES
PARTICULARLY AS THEY RELATE TO
EIGHTY USE.
SO JUST AS BACKGROUND IS BEEN MY
PROVIDES DRINKING WATER TO ONE
POINT FOUR MILLION CUSTOMERS IN
TWENTY CITIES IN TWO COUNTIES
ALAMEDA AND CONTRA COSTA IN THE
EASTERN SAN FRANCISCO BAY.
WE ALSO PROVIDE WASTEWATER
TREATMENT SIR FIVE THOUSAND
PEOPLE TO A SUBSET OF OUR
SERVICE OR THE KIND OF HUGS THE
WATER THERE --
WEIRD INDEPENDENT SPECIAL
DISTRICT SO --
WE'RE A LARGE AGENCY AND UNIQUE
IN THAT --
OTHER UTILITIES THAT ARE
GENERALLY ARE SIZE ARE USUALLY
PART OF A CITY OR COUNTY WE ARE
THE SECOND LARGEST RETAILER OF
WATER IN THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA
AND TWELFTH LARGEST IN THE
NATION.
SO OUR WATER DISTRIBUTION --
AND INFRASTRUCTURE AS YOU MIGHT
IMAGINE IS EXTENSIVE WE'VE GOT
YOU KNOW THOUSANDS OF MILES OF
DISTRIBUTION PIPE --
HUNDREDS OF PUMPING PLANTS
HUNDREDS OF NEIGHBORHOOD
RESERVOIRS AND THE WASTE WATER
DECIDED HOUSE WHAT WE DON'T ON
THE COLLECTION SYSTEM WE OWN THE
LARGE INTERCEPTORS THAT THOSE
CONNECT TO AND THE TREATMENT
FACILITIES THAT ACTUALLY
ULTIMATELY DISCHARGED INTO THE
BAY -- AND
OUR REVENUE STREAM --
AS TIM HAD ALSO MENTIONED IS
DIFFERENT THAN THAT OF A A CITY
OR A COUNTY THAT WE RELY
PRIMARILY ON THE RATES AND FEES
THAT WE CHARGE.
AND ALL THOSE OF COURSE ARE IN
ACCORDANCE WITH A PROP TO
EIGHTEEN AND PROP TO EIGHT DOT
TWENTY SIX NOW PART OF OUR
CONSTITUTION --
AND AND SO FORCE REFLECTING THE
COST OF SERVICE SO THOSE ARE THE
REFUSE THAT WE USE THIS COUNTRY
TO MAINTAIN TO UPGRADE OUR
INFRASTRUCTURE AND TO MEET
FUTURE SUPPLY DEMANDS.
SO -- THE
CONNECTION CAPACITY CHARGES
AREN'T --
AND AGAIN DAVID THANK YOU FOR
MENTIONING THAT YOU KNOW YOU
HAVE TO REALLY SIT DOWN WITH
WITH WATER AND SEWER BECAUSE
THESE ARE SIGNIFICANT COSTS --
AND YOU MAY ASK WHAT WE MEAN
WHEN WE TALK ABOUT THE
INFRASTRUCTURE --
FOR THE WATER SUPPLY TO SERVE
NEW DEVELOPMENT SO ESSENTIALLY
OUR MAJOR GOAL IS TO BE THERE
FOR NEW DEVELOPMENTS OUR NUMBERS
WE WANT TO MAKE SURE THAT THERE
ARE THOSE FACILITIES AND ALL THE
WATER SUPPLY AND EVERYTHING IS
THERE SO THAT WE'RE NOT A
HINDRANCE TO GROWTH THAT WERE.
REALLY THERE TO MAKE SURE THAT
WE MEET THAT FUTURE DEMAND AND
WE ALSO WANT TO MAKE SURE THAT
THAT FUTURE DEMAND --
IS ACCOUNTED FOR WHEN WE MAKE
OUR OUR PLANS AND CONSIDER
ADDITIONAL INVESTMENTS IN OUR
SYSTEM.
SO EXAMPLES OF THAT MEANS --
LOOKING AT SUFFICIENT STORAGE
CAPACITY WATER SUPPLIES PUMPING
CAPACITY --
OVER SIZING IN SOME CASES OF
DISTRIBUTION FACILITIES AND
PIPELINES OF WE KNOW THERE'S
BEEN A GROWTH IN IN CERTAIN
AREAS --
COORDINATING WITH THE CITIES
THAT ARE IN OUR EFFICIENT --
AT ALL TIMES OF DAY --
AND NIGHT --
BUT SIMPLY MAKING SURE THAT WE
HAVE ENOUGH TO MEET OUR PRESENT
IT OBVIOUSLY ISN'T ENOUGH WE
NEED TO MAKE SURE THAT WE HAVE
ENOUGH PRESSURE TO THE SYSTEM --
OUGHT TO BE ABLE TO FIGHT FIRES
FOR EXAMPLE AND THAT'S NOT AN
INTELLECTUAL EXERCISE FOR US --
AS YOU KNOW WE HAVE DIRECT
EXPERIENCE WITH DEVASTATING FIRE
IN OUR SERVICE AREA THE OAKLAND
HILLS FIRE EVEN TODAY IS.
CONSIDERED THE THIRD WORST FIRE
IN STATE HISTORY IN TERMS OF
LOSS OF LIFE AND PROPERTY.
SO ANY NEW DEMAND ON OUR SYSTEM --
IS IS SUCH THAT WE NEED TO MAKE
SURE THAT WE'VE GOT ALL OF THE
THE SUPPLY AND INFRASTRUCTURE TO
SERVE THAT AND THAT COSTS MONEY.
AND SO --
FOR US CONNECTION FEES AND
CAPACITY CHARGES ARE
FUNDAMENTALLY A PART OF A READ
AFFORDABILITY SO THAT'S KIND OF
THE NEXUS FROM OUR PERSPECTIVE --
THEY REALLY HELP TO ENSURE THAT
THOSE WHO BENEFIT FROM THE
DEVELOPMENT ARE ACTUALLY PAYING
THE COSTS THAT ARE ASSOCIATED
WITH --
SERVING THAT DEVELOPMENT --
WHAT HAPPENS IF WE DON'T RECOVER
THE COSTS FROM --
FROM THOSE FEES AND CHARGES WELL
ESSENTIALLY RATES ARE GOING TO
HAVE TO PAY FOR IT I MEAN AS TIM
HAD SAID EARLIER THE IT'S ONE OR
THE OTHER.
AND IN OUR CASE A SIGNIFICANT
PORTION OF OUR RATE BASIS LOW
INCOME WE ESTIMATE AT THIS POINT
THAT ONE THIRD OF OUR SERVICE
AREAS LIVING AT TUNER PERCENT OR
BELOW THE OF THE FEDERAL POVERTY
LIMIT.
SO AN ARC FROM OUR PERSPECTIVE
IT DOESN'T MAKE SENSE TO BURDEN
OUR REPAIRS PARTICULARLY OUR LOW
INCOME REPAIRS GIVEN PROP TWO
EIGHTEEN AND OTHER --
LONG EFFECT WITH THE COST OF NEW
DEVELOPMENT.
SO -- AT
PRESENT IN COMPLIANCE WITH STATE
LAW WE DO NOT CHARGE CAPACITY
FEES FOR EIGHTY USE UNLESS THE
SEPARATE STRUCTURE IS BEING
ADDED AND IF THAT SEPARATE
STRUCTURE ASKS IF THEY WANT TO
THAT IS ASKS US TO INCREASE
CAPACITY TO THEIR PARTICULAR
PROPERTY.
SO EVER PROPERTY OWNER
APPROACHES US WITH A NEW
STRUCTURE TERRORISTS IF IT'S YOU
KNOW INSIDE THE FOOTPRINT GREAT
NO PROBLEM --
BUT IF THEY PURCHASE NAY SAY
WELL WE'RE ACTUALLY HAVING A NEW
STRUCTURE AND WE THINK WE MIGHT
NEED SOME ADDITIONAL CAPACITY
WILL LOOK AT IT AND WILL EITHER
SAY ACTUALLY WE THINK YOU'RE
FINE ZERO YOU'RE GOOD DON'T
WORRY ABOUT IT.
OR WELL --
IT LOOKS LIKE YOU FOR WHATEVER
REASON YOU WANT TO A FIRE
SPRINKLER SYSTEM IN THAT UNIT
IT'S NOT REQUIRED BY LAW BUT YOU
WANT IT AND SO YOU'VE GOT A
REALLY OLD YOU KNOW FIVE EIGHT
CENTS LINE.
AS DAVID MENTIONED DIGGING INTO
THIS THINGS ARE EXPENSIVE AND SO --
WE WILL CHARGE THEM TO PUT IN A
NEW LINE AND TO PUT IN A NEW
METER AND SO THAT'S THAT'S A
SECOND COST AND THEN LET'S SAY
WELL YOU KNOW ACTUALLY WHAT
WE'RE REALLY TALKING ABOUT
ADDING A HOUSE THAT IS ABOUT THE
SAME SQUARE FOOTAGE IS THE
ORIGINAL HOUSE.
THAT'S FINE TOO BUT WE'LL JUST
LOOK AT WHAT SIZE LINE DO YOU
REALLY NEED AND IF YOU ALREADY
HAVE YOU KNOW A FIVE EIGHTHS
INCH LINE YOU WE CENTURY JUST
CHARGE YOU THE INCREMENTS UP TO
THE NEXT SIZE --
FOR CAPACITY SO THAT'S HOW IT'S
ACTUALLY WORKING IN IN PART AND
CURRENT PRACTICE AND ALL THOSE
CHARGES ARE FORCE IN ACCORDANCE
WITH STATE LAWS.
SO -- HAVE
TO PUT INTO PERSPECTIVE HOW ALL
THIS IS WORKING OR SERVICE OR AN
ARTICLE FROM FROM THE TURNER
CENTER I'M WHICH IS IN A LOT OF
GREAT WORK IN THIS AREA NOTED
THAT THE CITY OF OAKLAND SINCE
THE LAW CHANGED.
HAS RECEIVED A TWO HUNDRED FORTY
SEVEN EIGHTY YOU APPLICATIONS --
IN THE ELEVENTH MONTH PERIOD
FOLLOWING THE CHANGE IN THE LAW.
DURING THAT SAME PERIOD WE
RECEIVED ONLY EIGHT APPLICATIONS
FOR WATER SERVICE TO REVIEW
WHETHER AND EIGHTY YOU REQUIRED
ADDITIONAL --
WORK SO FROM OUR PERSPECTIVE
THAT'S WORKING JUST FINE AND
THAT WAS JUST OAKLAND ALONE
OVERALL --
OVER THAT PERIOD TWENTY FOUR WE
HAD IN OUR SERVICE AREA.
SO IN PRACTICE WERE NOT
GENERALLY NOTIFIED WHEN AN
EIGHTY USE BEING ADDED TO A
PROPERTY IF SOMEONE'S CHANGING
THEIR GARAGE AND THEIR THEIR
INTO AN EIGHTY YOU AN ADDITIONAL
SPACE.
WERENOT NOTIFIED --
AND AS LONG AS PROBLEM.
SO IN THE CASE TO BE SPENT MEDS
SERVICE ARE AT PRESENT I GUESS
IN IN KIND OF STARTING TO CLOSE --
WE DON'T HAVE ANY INFORMATION TO
SUGGEST THAT ARE UTILITY
CONNECTION FEES AND CAPACITY
CHARGES ARE IN ANY WAY HOLDING
BACK DEVELOPMENT OF EIGHTY USE
IT'S HAPPENING.
OF INSIDE OF THE FOOTPRINT OF
THE OF THE BUILDING --
YOU KNOW THERE'S THERE'S BEEN NO
PROBLEM AND AND FOR THE ONES
THAT ARE BUILDING NEW STRUCTURES
WERE WORKING WITH FOLKS.
SO --
CHARGES FOR NEW DEVELOPMENT
WHICH INCREASED DEMAND ON OUR
SYSTEM THOUGH SO THOSE WHERE
YOU'RE ACTUALLY ADDING LET'S SAY
THE SAME SQUARE FOOTAGE OF AN
ADDITIONAL --
HOME ON A LOT --
YOU DOES INCREASED DEMANDS ON
OUR SYSTEM AND BEING ABLE --
TO CHARGE YOU FOR THAT INCREASED
CAPACITY --
IS -- IS
IMPORTANT --
AS EIGHTY USE POTENTIALLY YOUR
BEING OFFERED AS AS PART OF A
SOLUTION FOR OUR OUR CRISIS IN
THE BAY AREA OF AFFORDABLE
HOUSING.
BE COULD REALLY REPRESENT A
SIGNIFICANT CHANGE IN IN HOUSING
DEVELOPMENT AND IN ACCOUNTING
FOR IN PLANNING FOR THOSE
DEMANDS ON OUR SYSTEM --
SO YOU MAY HAVE HEARD OF A
RECENT I'M 25% OF HOMEOWNER SAID
THAT THEY WOULD WOULD CONSIDER
SERIOUSLY ADDING AN EIGHTY YOU --
SO THAT WOULD BE ABOUT FOUR
HUNDRED THOUSAND UNITS I THINK I
THINK IT WAS FROM A TURNER
REPORT THAT MENTION THE BAY AREA
PULL BUT OVER ABOUT TWENTY YEARS
SO FOR OUR SINGLE FAMILY
RESIDENTIAL POPULATION.
THAT WOULD REPRESENT AROUND
NINETY THOUSAND EIGHTY USE OVER
TWENTY YEARS DIVIDED BY THE
THAT'S ABOUT FORTY FIVE HUNDRED
UNITS A YEAR.
THAT COULD POTENTIALLY BE ADDED
TO OUR SYSTEM --
WE ADDED FIVE HUNDRED SINGLE
FAMILY HOME EQUIVALENTS --
LAST YEAR FOR SFR IS NOT FOR
MULTI FAMILY SO --
IS SO FORTY FIVE HUNDRED VIEW IS
ABOUT TEN TIMES WHAT WE'RE
ADDING NOW AND SO THAT'S THAT'S
THAT IS SIGNIFICANT.
AND POTENTIALLY REPRESENTS AS AS
WE SAID AN ENTIRELY NEW HOUSING
PARADIGM WITH POTENTIALLY
SIGNIFICANT WATER WASTEWATER
SERVICE DEMANDS THAT WE WOULD
NEED TO PREPARE --
FOR SO WHEN'S NEW STRUCTURES ARE
BEING BUILT THAT RESULT IN
INCREASED DEMAND ON THE SYSTEM --
UTILITIES NEED TO BE ABLE TO
IMPOSE CONNECTION CAPACITY FEES
AND IF NOT THE RESPONSIBILITY
FOR THOSE COSTS WILL SIMPLY
SHIFT FROM --
YOU KNOW --
THE DEVELOPMENT TO THE REPAIRS --
AND THIS OF COURSE DRIVE
SEPARATES AND IN OUR CASE
PERSONALLY BURDENS THE OF A
SIGNIFICANT PORTION OF OUR
PARTICULAR SERVICE AREA.
SO THAT'S ARE PERSPECTIVE WE
HOPE IT'S HELPFUL --
AND WITH THAT THANK YOU FOR YOUR
TIME TODAY AND I'M AVAILABLE TO
ANSWERING QUESTIONS.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH FOR ITS HAS
BEEN HEARING QUESTIONS.
SHORTER THAN SAY I HAVE ONE
QUICK JUST COMMENT --
I REPRESENT RURAL AREAS AND SO
WHEN I THINK ABOUT SOME OF OUR
RURAL AREAS I AM CONCERNED
BECAUSE I KNOW THAT THEY'RE
INTERESTED IN YEAH. EIGHTY USE.
BUT IF THERE'S HOOK UPS AND
STUFF SOME OF OUR INFRASTRUCTURE
IN OUR OLDER COMMUNITIES ARE
WILL BE REALLY IMPACTED IN SO I
HATE TO SEE THEIR FEES GO UP BUT
I ALSO UNDERSTAND --
IT KIND OF OPENS UP A CAN OF
WORMS IN SOME COMMUNITIES
BECAUSE YOU GO TO FIX SOMETHING
AND IT JUST GOES FROM.
WORSE TO WORSE SO DURING OUR
TESTIMONY IN GOING FOR THEIR I
ALWAYS LOOK FORWARD TO OUR
HAVING CONVERSATIONS ABOUT HOW
DO WE MAKE SURE THIS KIND OF
LEGISLATION OR WHATEVER IT WORKS
FOR ALL COMMUNITIES OR DO WE
NEED SOME FLEXIBILITY FOR A REAL
COMMUNITY SO.
THANK YOU FOR YOUR COMMENTS
TODAY.
I HAD ONE FINAL QUESTION FOR MR
GARCIA FROM THE TURNER CENTER SO --
I AM LOOKING AT A REPORT FOR TWO
THOUSAND SEVENTEEN FROM YOUR
CENTER ABOUT THE SEATTLE
VANCOUVER --
AND PORTLET EXPERIENCES COULD
YOU TALK ABOUT WHAT POLICIES A
MOVE FORWARD --
THAT ARE DIFFERENT OR BETTER
THAN WHAT WE CAN DO WE'VE GOT
LESSONS TO LEARN.
SURE -- IN
JUST TO CLARIFY ABOVE
SPECIFICALLY FEES SO EL ALL
THEIR POLICIES WELL IT SEEMS AS
I JUST CAN THE EXECUTIVE SUMMARY
OF THE REPORT IT SEEMS LIKE --
THOSE THREE CITIES THAT HAVE
ALSO HAVE A LOT OF THE SAME
HOUSING ISSUES THAT WE DO HAVE
BAD MARKEDLY MORE SUCCESSFUL AT
EIGHTY PRODUCTION THEM
CALIFORNIA HAS IN RECENT YEARS.
WONDERING WHAT THEY'RE DOING
DIFFERENTLY --
SO -- I
WOULD SAY THAT --
THOSE THREE SPECIFIC CITIES HAVE
DONE A NUMBER OF THINGS --
THAT HAVE PRE DATE THE STATEWIDE
PERFORMS AT THE WE HAD JUST A
FEW YEARS AGO --
I ALREADY MENTIONED WITH
PORTLAND DID WITH REGARDS TO
FEES I THINK IT'S PRETTY CLEAR
THAT WAS A SIGNIFICANT --
STEP FORWARD IN THE DEVELOPMENT
EIGHTY USE IN PORTLAND --
BEFORE THAT CHANGE WAS MADE --
FEES WERE OFTEN TIMES CITED JUST
AS MUCH AS DESIGN REQUIREMENTS
AND FINANCING IS A MAJOR BARRIER
TO DEVELOPING A TO USE IN THAT
CITY -- IN
PLACES LIKE SEATTLE IN BEING
WHAT IS ACTUAL --
OUT ON ALIVE SO SET BACKS IF THE
OURS ARE THINGS THAT I THINK
HAVE BEEN CONSIDERED HERE AT THE
STATE LEVEL AS WELL --
ANOTHER INTERESTING COMPONENT TO
SOME OF THE CITIES HAVE
ADDRESSED IS ALSO THE ISSUE
VOTER OCCUPANCY.
AND THAT IN.
PORTLAND AND NO LONGER HAS --
WATER OCCUPANCY REQUIREMENTS AND
THEY HAVE SEEN SOME INCREASES
RESULT THEIR SOLUTIONS SOME OF
WHAT WE'VE SEEN --
DONE IN THESE OTHER CITIES THAT
POTENTIALLY COULD SERVE AS
MODELS FOR WHAT WE MAY WANT TO
DO HERE IN CALIFORNIA WHAT THE
WHETHER IT'S THE CITY LEVEL OR
PERHAPS AT THE STATE
[inaudible]
THANK YOU.
I WANT TO THANK THE PANEL FOR
YOUR INSIGHTS AND LOOK FOR TO
CONTINUE CONVERSATIONS ON THIS I
SUSPECT THIS WILL BE A A REAL
TOPIC THIS YEAR IN THE
LEGISLATURE.
WHEN WE GO NOW TO OUR FINAL
PANEL LIKE TO INVITE UP --
MISTER NECKLACE BACK UP TO THE
PODIUM FROM THE DEPARTMENT OF
HOUSING AND COMMUNITY
DEVELOPMENT --
MISTER ERIC PHILLIPS FROM THE
LAW FIRM OF GOLDFARB.
ELEVEN AND ALSO HIS VICE
PRESIDENT OF THE AMERICAN
PLANNING ASSOCIATION.
AND THERE ARE TWO VARMA WHO IS
THE DEPUTY DIRECTOR OF PLANNING
WITH THE CITY OF LOS ANGELES.
THE PANEL WILL BE DISCUSSING
CHALLENGES AND PAUL SINGULAR IT
CONSIDERATIONS FOR EIGHTY
DEVELOPMENT IN OUR STATE.
MR NICHOLS I KNOW YOU HAD A
CHANCE TO SPEAK EARLIER BUT LET
US KNOW ANY OTHER TOPICS YOU
WANT TO DISCUSS SOME OF THE
WOULD JUST --
JUST WANTED TO POINT OUT AGAIN
SOME OF THE IS UP WHEN WE GET
CONTACTED BY.
TELEPHONE OR EMAIL ABOUT ISSUES
THAT PEOPLE HAVE.
WELL TRYING TO OBTAIN A PERMIT
FOR AN EIGHTY YOU --
IF WE TALKED ABOUT A LOT HERE
SUBSTANTIAL FEES FOR SEWER WATER
UTILITIES IN THE IMPACT FEES
SUCH AS AMONGST MANY OTHERS BUT
TRANSPORTATION PARKS.
OF FEES ARE NOT OFTEN REVISED TO
BE PROPORTIONAL. TO THE IMPACT
OF THE PROJECT IS REQUIRED BY
LAW AND IT'S IMPORTANT TO NOTE
THAT.
WHILE A CD WILL DO A HIGH LEVEL
REVIEW OF FEES AS PART OF THE
HOUSING ELEMENT.
WE DO NOT REVIEW NEXUS STUDIES
ONE FOURTH PROVISIONS FOR THE
MEDICATION FEE ACT.
IN SOME CASES FEES ARE NOT AT A
LOCAL AGENCY CONTROL SUCH AS
SPECIAL DISTRICTS WATER
CORPORATIONS --
PARK FEES AND SCHOOLS.
ANOTHER EXAMPLE IS LOCAL AGENCY
REQUIREMENTS FOR THE CREATION OF
A NEW GARAGE WHEN THE GARAGE FOR
EXISTING SINGLE FAMILY DWELLING
IS CONVERTED TO AN EIGHTY YOU
EIGHTY LAWS --
IT ALLOWS THAT PARKING THAT
DISPLAYS PARKING IT WAS IN THE
GARAGE OF THE PRIMARY DWELLING
TO BE CONFIGURED.
ELSEWHERE ON THE LOT --
IN ADDITION TO SIGNIFICANTLY
IMPACTING COST CREATED EIGHTY
YOU THE REQUIREMENT TO REPLACE A
GARAGE STRUCTURE MAY ALSO REDUCE
THE POTENTIAL EIGHTY LOT
INVENTORY.
DUE TO THE NUMBER OF LOTS.
THAT COULD TWO LOT SIZE FLOOD
COVERAGE.
OR BUILDING SET BACKS.
EMAIL LOCATIONS THIS CONDITION
RESULTS IN A PROVISION FOR
EIGHTY USE PROPOSED TO BE
CREATED WITHIN THE SPACE OF AN
EXISTING GARAGE.
AND THEN WE HAVE ON OUR
OCCUPANCY CABINS WERE DEED
RESTRICTION REQUIREMENTS BY
LOCAL AGENCIES MAY CONSTRAIN
MANY OWNERS.
FROM CREATING AN EIGHTY YOU. TO
THE CONCERN THAT WHEN THE
PROPERTY SOLD.
IT MUST BE PURCHASED BY WITH A
COMMITMENT BY THE BUYER. TO
RESIDE AT THE PROPERTY OR AS
MANY COVENANTS REQUIRE.
THE MAY CREATE A COMMITMENT THEY
MAY BE REQUIRED TO REMOVE THE
VIDEO --
MINIMUM LOT SIZE CONSTRAINTS --
COME UP FAIRLY OFTEN WE HAVE
SOME THAT HAVE BEEN --
WELL OVER TEN THOUSAND SQUARE
FEET -- THE
SUBSTANTIALLY LIMIT THE NUMBER
OF LOTS AVAILABLE FOR EIGHTY YOU --
AND MAY WITH SMALLER LAW TO
ALLOW ANY DO YOU PICK TO BE
CREATED.
AND LASTLY WE HEAR ABOUT FIRE
SPRINKLERS REQUIRED FOR NEEDY
YOU BY LOCAL AGENCY BUILDING
DEPARTMENT OR FIRE DEPARTMENTS
EVEN THOUGH THEY ARE EXEMPT.
WHEN THE PRIMARY DWELLING?
IS NOT REQUIRE THERE'S PICTURES
THAT'S SORT OF LIKE THAT BUT
ABOUT THE TOP FIVE OF THE ISSUES
THAT WE WE ARE --
ASKED ABOUT A COME [inaudible]
THE SPLASHES.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH QUESTIONS.
LET'S MOVE TO MISTER PHILLIPS --
VERY HAPPY TO BE HERE THIS
MORNING THANK YOU FOR HAVING ME
MY NAME IS ERIC PHILLIPS I'M A
LAWYER WITH GOLDFARB AND LET MEN
WHERE A A FIRM BASED IN OAKLAND --
WE REPRESENT BOTH PRIVATE
HOUSING DEVELOPERS PRIMARILY --
NONPROFIT AFFORDABLE HOUSING
DEVELOPERS AND PUBLIC AGENCIES --
I PERSONALLY HAVE WORKED WITH
MANY CITIES AND COUNTIES WRITING
THERE AT YOU ORDINANCES SINCE
TWENTY SIXTEEN AND I'M HAPPY TO
SAY THAT NONE OF THE ISSUES THAT
MR NECKLACE --
JUST BROUGHT UP OR IN ANY OF THE
ORDINANCES I'VE WORKED ON SO --
I HATE A TO THAT THOSE ARE
DEFINITELY AT RULES THAT ARE
CLEAR IN THE LAW AND AND PEOPLE
SHOULD BE FOLLOWING THE MIKE I
AGREE -- BUT
TODAY I'M HERE --
IN MY ROLE WITH THE AMERICAN
PLANNING ASSOCIATION CALIFORNIA
CHAPTER I AM THE VICE PRESIDENT
FOR POLICY AND LEGISLATION AND
I'M HERE TO SHARE --
THAT ORGANIZATIONS PERSPECTIVE
USE AND THE PLANNING PRINCIPLES
THAT NEED TO BE CONSIDERED WHEN
WE'RE LOOKING AT EIGHTY USE AS
PART OF THE SOLUTION TO OUR
STATE'S HOUSING CRISIS.
AS AN ORGANIZATION --
EPA HAS APPROXIMATELY FIVE
THOUSAND MEMBERS THROUGHOUT THE
STATE -- FOR
PROFESSIONAL PLANNERS --
FROM BOTH PUBLIC AGENCIES AND
PRIVATE ORGANIZATIONS GOVERNMENT
OFFICIALS AND MEMBERS OF THE
PUBLIC AND AS AN ORGANIZATION WE
HAVE STRONG SUPPORT FOR THE
DEVELOPMENT OF EIGHTY YEARS
THROUGHOUT THE STATE WE
RECOGNIZE.
THAT IT'S AN IMPORTANT SOURCE OF
HOUSING --
TO ADDRESS THAT THE CRISIS THAT
WE FACE --
AND WE ALSO SUPPORT DEVELOPMENT
STANDARDS AND INCENTIVES THAT
WILL ENCOURAGE THE DEVELOPMENT
OF EIGHTY USE THERE WERE SOME
QUESTIONS.
EARLIER THAT BROUGHT SOME
EXAMPLES TO MIND THAT I'D LIKE
TO SHARE BEFORE EIGHT I TOUCH ON
SOME OF MADE.
THE BULK OF MY COMMENTS --
BUT THERE WERE THERE WAS A
QUESTION ABOUT --
BOTH INCENTIVES FOR EIGHTY
PRODUCTION AND MAKING SURE THAT
THEIR OF EIGHTY USE ARE
AFFORDABLE AND I THINK THERE'S
AN OPPORTUNITY.
TO HEAR THOSE TWO TOGETHER --
AS RECENTLY A LOAN PRO WHERE --
IS CAN BORROW --
LOW INTEREST LOANS FROM THE
COUNTY -- IN
EXCHANGE FOR HAVING DEED
RESTRICTIONS ON EIGHTY USE THAT
THEY CREATE ON THEIR PROPERTY TO
ENSURE THAT THOSE ARE.
ACTUALLY BEING USED TO INCREASE
THE AFFORDABLE HOUSING STOCK NOT
JUST HOUSING STOCK IN GENERAL --
AT A NON GOVERNMENTAL AGENCY THE
HOUSING TRUST OF SILICON VALLEY
IS ALSO --
LAUNCHING A SIMILAR PROGRAM SO --
THERE ARE OPPORTUNITIES THE
STATE CURRENTLY DOESN'T REQUIRE
AFFORDABILITY AND LARGE EIGHTY
IS UP TO TWELVE HUNDRED SQUARE
FEET CERTAINLY WON'T BE
AFFORDABLE BY DEFINITION --
BUT HAVING OTHER INCENTIVES TO
CREATE THE PRODUCTION OF
EIGHTIES AND TYING THAT TO
AFFORDABILITY CERTAINLY MAKES
SENSE --
ANOTHER EXAMPLE AND WANTED TO
SHARE --
COMES RIGHT ASSEMBLY MEMBER
GLORIA LEFT BUT IT'S FROM THE
NORTHERN SAN DIEGO COUNTY AND
THE CITY OF ENCINITAS HAS
RECENTLY --
ADOPTED PRE APPROVED EIGHTY YOU
PLANS AND THE CITY TO FUNDED
CONSTRUCTION DOCUMENTS --
FOR I THINK TWELVE DIFFERENT
VARIATIONS OF EIGHTY USE RIGHT
RANGING FROM STUDIO ALL THE WAY
UP TO THREE BEDROOM --
LIVING UNITS THAT THE CITY PAID
FOR THE DESIGN HOMEOWNERS CAN
COME AND GET THOSE CONSTRUCTION
DRAWINGS FOR FREE THE CITY HAS
PRE PERMITTED THEM.
SO THE DESIGN COSTS AND
PERMITTING COSTS ARE GREATLY
REDUCED FOR HOMEOWNERS --
AND THAT'S A WAY TO REDUCE THE
BARRIER FOR CREATING EIGHTY
YEARS WHILE HAVING DESIGNS THAT.
THE NEIGHBORS HAVE ALL OVER THE
CITY HAS ALREADY REFLECT LOCAL
CONDITIONS AND CONCERNS --
AND THAT LEADS A SPEEDIER AND
LESS COSTLY PRODUCTION OF OF
EIGHTIES ON THE PART OF THE
HOMEOWNERS --
SO THOSE ARE SOME IDEAS OF
THINGS THAT ARE WORKING WELL
UNDER THAT THE CURRENT LAWS THAT
WE HAVE.
AND AS WE THINK OF WAYS TO YOU --
CONTINUE TO ENCOURAGE EIGHTY
DEVELOPMENT GOING FORWARD I DID
WANT TO HIGHLIGHT A FEW AREAS --
WHERE WE SHOULD ALSO BE THINKING
ABOUT --
LIMITATIONS AND CHALLENGES TO
ADDRESS --
AS WERE MENTIONED IN AN OPENING
REMARKS AND THAT CONTEXT MATTERS
FOR WHERE WE'RE PUTTING EIGHTY
USE -- PART
OF GOOD PLANNING A CERTAINLY
THINKING OF CONTEXT SENSITIVE
REGULATIONS I DON'T SPEAK JUST A
LITTLE BIT ABOUT.
WHY SOME ONE SIZE FITS ALL
STANDARDS DON'T REALLY WORK --
FROM MY PERSPECTIVE FOR EIGHTY
YEARS ESPECIALLY WHEN WE'RE
CONSIDERING THE VARIATIONS IN
HOUSING DEMANDED ENVIRONMENTAL
FACTORS BETWEEN RURAL AND URBAN
INFILL AREAS THAT'S AN IMPORTANT
DISTINCTION --
YOUR EARLIER PANEL SPOKE QUITE A
BIT ABOUT FEES AND
INFRASTRUCTURE SO I WON'T SPEND
MUCH TIME ON IT BUT I DO WANT TO
EMPHASIZE THAT.
PROPER PLANNING REQUIRES
RELATING GROSS TO THE CAPACITY
TO SUPPORT THAT GROWTH AND
MAKING SURE THAT OUR COMMUNITIES
CAN ABSORB THE GROWTH THAT'S
PLANNED FOR THEM.
AND PLANNING ALSO REQUIRES HAVE
STABILITY AND CONSISTENCY SO
THAT WE CAN RESPOND TO AN
IMPLEMENT CHANGES THAT HAVE
HAPPENED ALREADY --
SO.
FOCUSING SPECIFICALLY ON THE
CONTEXT SENSITIVITY AND AND
THOSE RELATED ISSUES --
I AS AN ORGANIZATION AT
CALIFORNIA EPA WITH SUPPORTS.
ALLOWING AN INDIVIDUAL EIGHTY
YOU IN AN ALMOST ANY EXISTING
STRUCTURE FOR THE REASONS THAT
WE HEARD FROM THE PANELISTS
EARLIER TODAY --
AS LONG AS THOSE ARE ARE PAIRED
WITH.
LOT COVERAGE STANDARDS THAT
WOULD PERMIT.
PERMIT NEW DETACHED EIGHTY YEARS
AND THOSE ARE BOTH.
A REASONABLE WAYS TO ALLOW NEW
EIGHTY YEARS WHILE STILL I AM
HAVING SOME.
CHECK ON ON THE AMOUNT OF GROWTH --
BUT THE CONTEXT I THINK DESERVES
TO BE TREATED DIFFERENTLY --
AS I MENTIONED BETWEEN URBAN
INFILL AREAS AND RURAL AREAS I'M.
THINKING SPECIFICALLY OF RURAL
AREAS -- I'M
WARY OF ENCOURAGING TOO MUCH
GROWTH IN AREAS WHERE THERE'S
NOT TRANSIT ACCESS --
OR EVEN NEARBY SERVICES I THINK
THAT THAT --
HAVING MULTIPLE EIGHTY USE ON
MORE RURAL LOTS --
RUNS THE RISK OF INCREASING
VEHICLE MILES TRAVELED AND
POTENTIALLY EVEN RUNNING COUNTER
TO SEE SOME OF THE I. GHG
REDUCTION GOALS AND CLIMATE
POLICIES THAT WE HAVE --
DIFFERENT CONTEXT AGAIN FOR
URBAN INFILL SITE --
SO AS WE'RE LOOKING AT WAYS TO
INTENSIFY EIGHTY YEARS HAVING
THOSE BE OPTING PROGRAMS ARE
HAVING DIFFERENT ROLES BETWEEN --
RURAL AND URBAN AREAS MAKES A
LOT OF SENSE --
I'M ALSO SENSITIVE TO RURAL
AREAS WHERE AGRICULTURE REMAINS
PREVALENT AND THE MORE
RESIDENTIAL USES THAT ARE
BROUGHT INTO AGRICULTURAL AREAS --
THE MORE AT RISK THOSE ACT
AGRICULTURAL PRESERVATION
EFFORTS BECOMES AND I'M I WANT
TO BE SENSITIVE TO THAT.
AND ASK THAT THAT BE PART OF THE
CONCERT EIGHTY YEARS ARE
ENCOURAGED AND PERMITTED --
AND THEN I ALSO AM.
IN LATE SPECTACULARLY ITS TOP OF
MIND I'M FOLLOWING THE PAST TWO
YEARS OF FIRES.
WHERE WE PERMIT GROWTH HAS A
DRASTIC CONSEQUENCES FOR THE
SCALE AND SCOPE OF THOSE TYPES
OF DISASTERS --
AND MAKING SURE THAT AT LEAST
THERE'S OPPORTUNITIES FOR
SENSIBLE LOCAL CONTROLS THAT
WILL REDUCE FIRE HAZARDS AS
RESIDENTIAL DEVELOPMENT
INTENSIFIES IS AN IMPORTANT
POINT --
MINIMUM STANDARDS --
IN URBAN AREAS AROUND FAR IN LOT
COVERAGE.
ALLOWING SOME LOCAL FLEXIBILITY
FOR THOSE TYPES OF STANDARDS IS
IMPORTANT IT HELPS INSURE GREEN
SPACE AN OTHERWISE BUILT OUT
ENVIRONMENTS.
AND IT CAN HELP REDUCE
NEIGHBORHOOD OPPOSITION TO NEW.
RESIDENTIAL DEVELOPMENT AND
INTENSIFICATION AND WITHIN THOSE
AREAS -- AND
IN MORE RURAL AREAS --
Là COVERAGE F. A. R. ESPECIALLY
SETBACKS BECOME REALLY IMPORTANT
TO PROVIDING DEFENSIBLE SPACES
TO MINIMIZE FIRE RISK --
SO MAKING SURE THAT THERE IS A
LOCAL ABILITY TO HAVE --
APPROPRIATE IN CONTEXT SENSITIVE
RULES AROUND THAT IS IS AGAIN
JUST VERY IMPORTANT --
I DID WANT TO PICK UP ON A
COMMENT THAT --
DAVID GOING FROM SANTA ROSA HAD
SHARED EARLIER THAT IN SMALL
EIGHTY USE --
LIKELY DON'T HAVE THEM ANYMORE
IMPACT ON THE RESIDENTIAL --
HOME --
WOULD INDEPENDENTLY AND AND THAT --
BUT AS EIGHTY USE THAT ARE
PERMITTED ALL THE WAY UP TO
TWELVE HUNDRED SQUARE FEET --
COME INTO PLAY WHEN I LIVE IN A
THREE BEDROOM TWELVE HUNDRED
SQUARE FOOT AND HOUSE AND
BERKELEY.
AND THAT THAT'S NO DIFFERENT --
IN TERMS OF IMPACT THAN --
A LARGE EIGHTY YEARS SO I'M
THINKING ABOUT THE SIZE AND AS
WORLD ALLOWING LARGER EIGHTY USE
MAKING SURE THAT COMMUNITIES AND
HAVE THE ABILITY TO ABSORB THAT
GROWTH AS WE INCREASED
POPULATION DENSITY THREE LARGER
EIGHTY YEARS.
AND THERE WILL BE AN INCREASED
DEMAND ON SERVICE SAYS --
SEWER AND WATER CAPACITY ROSE
TRANSIT SCHOOLS I AM IT IT IS
IMPORTANT TO KEEP THAT IN MIND --
ESPECIALLY IF MORE THAN ONE
EIGHTY YOU WAS GOING TO BE
PERMITTED HER A LOT --
I THINK IT WOULD BE ACCEPTABLE
TO YOU.
ALLOW JURISDICTIONS TO PERMIT
THAT I AM ESPECIALLY IF THEY CAN
DO YOU THE ANALYSIS TO MAKE SURE
THAT THEIR COMMUNITIES CAN
ABSORB.
THAT INTENSIVE INTENSIFIED
GROWTH BUT MAKING THAT SORT OF
REAL MANDATORY --
I THINK RUNS THE RISK OF
STRAINING AND THE EAST BAY
MUNICIPAL.
UTILITY DISTRICT ABOUT AND THAT
AGENCIES POTENTIAL CHALLENGES --
SCALING UP TWENTY YEARS FROM NOW
I THINK THAT THAT COULD BE EVEN
MORE INTENSIFIED LOOKING AT
WATER AND SEWER SERVICE ISSUES
AND RURAL COMMUNITIES THINKING
OF RESIDENTIAL AREAS THAT ARE ON
WELLS AND SEPTIC SERVICE.
ALLOWING.
LARGE OR MULTIPLE EIGHTY YEARS
ON THOSE TYPES OF PROPERTIES --
DOESN'T SEEM LIKE IT MAKES SENSE
IN RELATION TO THEIR CAPACITY TO
ABSORB AT AND THE ABILITY AGAIN
TO HAVE --
SOME LOCAL --
REGULATIONS TO MONITOR THAT IS
REMAINS IMPORTANT --
AND I ALSO AT NOT TO KEEP
PICKING ON DAVID BUT HIS
COMMENTS FROM ABOUT HOW SANTA
ROSA HAS HANDLED THEIR FEES.
IS A VERY.
CREATIVE AND SENSIBLE WAY TO
SCALE.
THE SIZE AND IMPACT OF ACTUAL
EIGHTY YOU DEVELOPMENT --
CONTRASTING THAT WITH A PROPOSAL
TO YOU ELIMINATE ALL FEES
ALTOGETHER ESPECIALLY
CONSIDERING THE SIZE OF THE
LARGEST EIGHTY USE THAT ARE
PERMITTED --
AND THEN AS THEY CAN BEGIN TO
CONCLUDE MY REMARKS --
AGAIN IT AS A PLANNING AGENCY --
ARE AT PLANNING ORGANIZATION I'M.
WITH DO YOU LOOK TO HAVE SOME
PREDICTABILITY AND STABILITY
STABILITY AROUND --
THE RULES THAT ARE --
GOVERNING DEVELOPMENT SO THAT WE
CAN IMPLEMENT THEM AS
PROFESSIONALS --
I KNOW SAN MATEO COUNTY WAS
BROUGHT UP AS A JURISDICTION
THAT'S DOING A GOOD JOB WITH
EIGHTY PRODUCTION.
THAT JURISDICTION WORKED WITH
THAT THAT TWENTY INCORPORATED
CITIES WITHIN SAN MATEO COUNTY --
TO DO A COLLABORATIVE PLANNING
EFFORT TO UPDATE THEIR EIGHTY
YOU ORDINANCES TOGETHER --
IN TWENTY SIXTEEN AND TO YOU --
COME UP WITH SHARED STANDARD --
CONTACTS IN THAT REGION --
AND THE IT WAS A LARGE PLANNING
EFFORT TO ROLL OUT AND AND GET
THE RULES IN PLACE AND EFFECTIVE
SO THAT THEY WERE COMPLYING WITH
STATE LAW AND ABLE TO ENCOURAGE.
EIGHTY YOU DEVELOPMENT AND I
JUST AND WARY OF TOO MANY
CHANGES TOO FAST THAT WOULD UNDO
THAT GOOD WORK OR CONTINUE TO
BURDEN --
PLANNING STAFFS AND AS THEY RUN
BACK TO ME TO UPDATE THEIR
ORDINANCE EVERY YEAR --
I LIKE IT BUT AS A THE AS A
POLICY MATTER THAT MAYBE IS NOT
THE BEST USE OF THE RESOURCES
THEY COULD BE FOCUSED ON
INCENTIVES AND PUTTING THAT
TOWARDS ACTUAL DEVELOPMENT OF
EIGHTY YEARS --
SO AS ALL OF THE PANELISTS HAVE
SPOKEN BEFORE WE'RE SEEING
RESULTS FROM THE CHANGES THAT
HAVE HAPPENED ALREADY.
AND WE'RE HAPPY TO LET THAT
PROCESS CONTINUE AND BELIEVE
THAT WE CAN PROVIDE MORE HOUSING
AND WELL PLANNED COMMUNITIES
COMMUNITIES SIMULTANEOUSLY --
BY CREATING OPTIONAL PER AB
PROVISIONS OFFERING INCENTIVES.
AND TECHNICAL ASSISTANCE WHERE
NECESSARY TO HELP MAKE THAT
HAPPEN AND AGAIN THANK YOU FOR
HAVING ME HERE TODAY AND I'M
HAPPY TO ANSWER ANY QUESTIONS OR
PROVIDE.
ADDITIONAL RESOURCES.
ANY QUESTIONS FOR MISTER
PHILLIPS THIS MOMENT.
I'LL MAKE ONE COMMENT THANK YOU
SAYING THEY WERE RURAL A COUPLE.
TO THANK YOU WHEN WE MOVED TO
MISS MARTHA.
GOOD MORNING.
MY NAME IS ARE THE OF OUR MIND
THE DEPUTY DIRECTOR OF AYE CITY
WIDE POLICY PLANNING AT THE CITY
OF LOS ANGELES PLANNING
DEPARTMENT --
HERE TO GIVE A LITTLE BIT OF A
DEPARTMENTAL PERSPECTIVE --
MIGHT AD BUREAU OVERSEAS THE
GENERAL PLAN INCLUDES THE
HOUSING ELEMENT OF OUR CITY --
IT ALSO INCLUDES TARGETED TO
REGULATE HOUSING AND PRODUCTION
OF AFFORDABLE HOUSING IN THE
CITY SAID THANK YOU.
FOR INVITING ME TO SPEAK HERE
TODAY I'M GONNA SHARE OUR
EXPERIENCE IN THE CITY OF LA
WITH OUR WITH ACCESSORY DWELLING
UNITS SO.
AS THE LITTLE BIT OF BACKGROUND
THE CITY ADOPTED ITS FIRST.
SECOND DWELLING UNIT AT THE TIME
ORDINANCE IN NINETEEN EIGHTY
FIVE THE ORDINANCE REQUIRED A
CONDITIONAL USE PERMIT --
IT RESTRICTED EIGHTY USED TO
APPROXIMATELY 20% OF THE PARCELS
IN THE CITY.
AND HAD PARKING REQUIREMENTS
LIMITATIONS ON SQUARE FOOTAGE --
LIMITED ABOUT SIX HUNDRED SQUARE
FEET -- AND
IT HAD A PASSAGEWAY REQUIREMENTS.
IT UP TEN FEET FREE AND CLEAR UP
TO THE SKY BETWEEN ALL
STRUCTURES WHICH EFFECTIVELY
LIMITED THE PRODUCTION OF EIGHTY
USED TO ABOUT TEN TO TWENTY A
YEAR.
THE CITY'S MOST RECENT HOUSING
ELEMENT --
YOU KNOW IN THE IN THE WAKE OF
THE HOUSING CRISIS IDENTIFIED
EIGHTY USE AS AN IMPORTANT
SOURCE OF HOUSING FOR THE CITY.
IN FACT ONE OF THE
IMPLEMENTATION PROGRAMS OUT OF
THE HOUSING ELEMENT SPECIFICALLY
CALLED FOR THE CITY TO DO
AMONGST OTHER THINGS.
IDENTIFY OBSTACLES TO ENABLING
SECOND UNITS ON SINGLE FAMILY
LOTS AND TO PROPOSE WAYS TO
ADDRESS THE OBSTACLES THROUGH
ADOPTION OF ZONING CODE
AMENDMENTS TO ALLEVIATE THOSE
CHALLENGES.
A SO WE WE'VE BEEN WORKING ON
THIS -- YOU
KNOW THROUGH OUR GENERAL PLAN
POLICIES --
TO FACILITATE THE PRODUCTION OF
ACCESSORY DWELLING UNITS GIVEN
SORT OF THE POTENTIAL LARGE
OPPORTUNITY IN THE CITY OF LOS
ANGELES HAVE 70% OF OUR CITY IS.
A SINGLE FAMILY WE HAVE FIVE
HUNDRED DETACHED SINGLE FAMILY
HOMES IN THE CITY SO THEY'RE
REAL OPPORTUNITY.
TO EXPLORE THE PRODUCTION OF
ACCESSORY DWELLING UNITS AS A
SOLUTION IN OUR HOUSING ELEMENT.
THE MOST DRAMATIC CHANGE THAT WE
SAW IN HOUSING PRODUCTION AND
EIGHTY USE CAME WITH THE STATE
LAW CHANGES IN.
TWENTY SEVENTEEN SO SINCE THE
PASSAGE OF AB TWENTY TWO NINETY
NINE AND SB TEN SIXTY NINE THE
CITY OF LOS ANGELES AS LOCAL
ORDINANCE HAS BEEN DECLARED NULL
AND VOID AND WE'VE BEEN
OPERATING UNDER.
A STATE LAW WE DO HAVE A LOCAL
ORDINANCE UNDER CONSIDERATION BY
CITY COUNCIL BUT IT HAS NOT YET
BEEN ADOPTED --
SO I JUST WANT TO TALK A LITTLE
BIT ABOUT --
SOME OF OUR NUMBERS UNDER STATE
LAW THAT WE'VE SEEN A DRAMATIC
INCREASE IN THE NUMBER OF EIGHTY
USE.
IN TWENTY EIGHTEEN ALONE WE HAD
FIVE THOUSAND FOUR HUNDRED AND
TWENTY NINE BUILDING PERMITS
RECEIVED FOR ACCESSORY DWELLING
UNITS THAT WAS JUST --
TWENTY EIGHTEEN SINCE TWENTY
SEVENTEEN WHEN JANUARY FIRST ONE
STATE LAW CHANGES WHEN INTO A
FACT WE HAVE A TOTAL OF NINE
THOUSAND TWO HUNDRED AND FORTY
SEVEN BUILDING PERMITS RECEIVED
FOR ACCESSORY DWELLING UNITS.
THIS REPRESENTS AN APPROXIMATELY
THIRTY FOLD INCREASE FROM THAT
SEVERAL YEARS PRIOR WHEN WE ARE
OPERATING UNDER THE NINETEEN
EIGHTY FIVE ORDINANCE WHERE
AGAIN WE WERE WE WERE GETTING
YOU KNOW --
TEN TO TWENTY APPLICATIONS A
YEAR --
WE'RE SEEING A IS AN THE THE
PAST TWO YEARS WE'RE SEEING AN
UPWARD TREND CONTINUING SO --
RIGHT WHEN WE FIRST STARTED AND
SHE A COUPLE HUNDRED
APPLICATIONS COMING IN EVERY
MONTH NOW WE'RE AT APPROXIMATELY
FOUR HUNDRED APPLICATIONS COMING
IN A MONTH FOR ACCESSORY
DWELLING UNITS --
IN TERMS OF DISTRIBUTION WE WENT
THROUGH AND MAPPING EXERCISE TO
TAKE A LOOK AT WHERE THESE IDEAS
WERE COMING UP THROUGHOUT THE
CITY -- AND
GENERALLY THE THE ACCESSORY
DWELLING UNITS SEEM TO BE WELL
DISPERSED THROUGHOUT THE CITY --
THEIR GREATEST CONCENTRATIONS
ARE IN THE SAN FERNANDO VALLEY
IN AREAS SUCH AS SUN VALLEY
NORTH HOLLYWOOD VAN NUYS THOSE
ARE PARTS OF OUR CITY WHERE WE
TEND TO HAVE LARGER LOT SIZES --
BUT THERE ARE ALSO MANY EIGHTY
USE --
ACROSS THE CITY AND AND WEST LA
AND IN SOUTH LA THESE ARE
NEIGHBORHOODS THAT REPRESENTS --
YOU KNOW DIVERSE DEMOGRAPHICS
BEING A REP YOU KNOW RANGING
FROM LOW INCOME COMMUNITIES OF
COLOR TO WEALTHIER COMMUNITIES
SO WE'RE SEEING IT --
A EXCESS REELING IS REALLY
DISPERSED ACROSS THE CITY --
IT'S IMPORTANT TO NOTE THAT
ABOUT 45% OF ALL THE EIGHTY YOU
PERMITS THAT OF THAT NINE
THOUSAND THAT I MENTIONED
EARLIER --
OUR CONVERSIONS OF EXISTING
SPACE -- YOU
KNOW DUE TO THE SPECIFIC
REGULATIONS UNDER STATE LAW WITH
RESPECT TO CONVERSIONS --
WHEN THAT WHEN WE WHEN THE STATE
LAW FIRST CAME VERSION SO I
THINK THIS IS BEEN AN IMPORTANT
COMPONENT OF --
THE REGULATIONS OF THAT STATE
LAW THAT'S REALLY ALLOWED FOR
THE CREATION OF A TO USE IN THE
CITY OF LOS ANGELES --
THE REMAINDER OF THE EIGHTY USE
CONSIST OF ABOUT 35% ADDITIONS
AND 20% NEW CONSTRUCTION --
OTHER ASPECTS OF THE STATE LAW
THAT HAVE LIKELY RESULTED IN THE
EIGHTY YOU PRODUCTION INCREASES
THE REMOVAL OF THE PASSAGEWAY
REQUIREMENT THAT WAS A REAL
BARRIER FOR US.
IN LOS ANGELES ALSO THE REMOVAL
REMOVAL I HAVE --
MINIMUM LOT SIZE AND THAT'S
WHERE THE INCREASE OF SQUARE
FOOTAGE LIMITATIONS --
TO TWELVE HUNDRED AS WELL AS THE
PARKING THE CITY OF LOS ANGELES
IS.
YOU KNOW A FEW AREAS OF THE CITY
OF LOS ANGELES REQUIRE PARKING
DUE TO ADJACENCY TO TRANSIT.
I GET ALL THIS PRODUCTION HAS
OCCURRED UNDER STATE LAW --
I MENTIONED THERE IS A LOCAL
ORDINANCE UNDER CONSIDERATION BY
THE LA CITY COUNCIL THIS
ORDINANCE IS LOOKING AT LIMITING
EIGHTY USE IN CERTAIN HIVE FIRE
HAZARD SEVERITY ZONES WITH
LIMITED ST APT ACCESS --
WE'VE DONE SOME ANALYSIS WE
DON'T ANTICIPATE THAT THIS
RESTRICTION SHOULD THE LOCAL
ORDINANCE BE ADOPTED --
THAT WILL DRAMATICALLY CHANGE
THE NUMBERS ONLY ABOUT 2% EIGHTY
USE OF OF THAT NINE THOUSAND I
MENTIONED --
HAVE BEEN IN THIS TYPE BUYER
HAZARD SEVERITIES ON MOST OF THE
AGAIN MOST I HAVE BEEN
CONVERSIONS WHICH WOULD CONTINUE
TO BE ALLOWED --
OUR LOCAL ORDINANCES ALSO
EXPLORING --
PERMITTING MOVABLE TINY HOMES AS
A TYPE OF ACCESSORY DWELLING
UNIT WHICH TODAY IS CURRENTLY
NOT PERMITTED IN OUR ZONING CODE --
ONE OF THE CHALLENGES THAT WE'VE
HEARD MANY EIGHTY YOU APPLICANTS
ENCOUNTERING IN LOS ANGELES IS
COMPLEX WITH LADWP EASEMENTS.
SO THIS IS AN ISSUE LARGELY
CENTERED AROUND POWER LINES THAT
EXTENDS OVER MANY BACKYARDS
ALLEYWAYS IN THE CITY OF LOS
ANGELES.
OUR LOCAL UTILITY LA W. P. --
ESTABLISHED LOCAL REGULATIONS IN
THE NINETEEN EIGHTIES --
THAT PREVENT ANY HOW IT'LL
STRUCTURES WITHIN A UTILITY
EASEMENT AND NO CONSTRUCTION
WHATSOEVER UNDERNEATH THE DRIP
LINE SO THESE LOCAL ROLES
ACTUALLY GO BEYOND.
THIS WHAT HAS BEEN ESTABLISHED
AT THE STATE WIDE UTILITY LEVEL
THREE GENERAL ORDER NINETY FIVE
A WHICH ALLOWS SOME LEVEL OF
CONSTRUCTION UNDER THE DRIP LINE
WITH -- WITH
WITH A CERTAIN DISTANCE AND ALSO
I HAVE ALLOWS CONSTRUCTION
WITHIN A SIX BUT EASEMENT AROUND
THE POWER LINE --
WITH WE'VE LEARNED THAT LED DB
W. P. HAS BEEN --
HAS THESE MORE RESTRICTIVE
REGULATIONS BECAUSE OF THE
TECHNOLOGY THAT DELUDE P.
EMPLOYS WHERE AND IF A POWER
LINE DROPS IT REMAINS ACTIVE AND
REMAINS LIVE --
OTHER UTILITIES SUCH AS AT AS AN
EMPLOYEE TECHNOLOGY WHERE WHEN
THE POWER LINE DROPS IT IN AND
IT IMMEDIATELY BECAUSE BECOMES
AN ACTIVE --
SO THESE THESE EASEMENT 20% OF
OUR EIGHTY YOU APPLICATIONS THAT
ARE COMING IN --
WE'RE CONTINUING TO ADVANCE
DISCUSSIONS WITH THE D. W. P. --
TO FIND POTENTIAL SOLUTIONS TO
THIS ISSUE --
AND SAFETY CONTINUES TO BE A
PARAMOUNT --
DISCUSSION ITEM --
AT THESE MEETINGS.
I DID ALSO WANT TO TAKE A MOMENT
TO MENTION SOME OF THE EFFORTS
THAT HAVE BEEN OCCURRING WITH
EIGHTY USE IN THE CITY OF LOS
ANGELES THROUGH THE MAYOR'S
OFFICE --
THE MAYOR'S OFFICE IS INNOVATION
TEAM IN PARTICULAR --
SO FIRST OF THE MAYOR'S OFFICE
HAS BEEN WORKING ON AN EIGHTY
YOU PILOT OVER THE LAST SEVERAL
YEARS THROUGH THIS PILOT PROGRAM
THE CITY HAS PROVIDED A GRANTS
TO A HOUSEHOLD IN HIGHLAND PARK
NEIGHBORHOOD OF LOS ANGELES ON
WHERE THE HOMEOWNER WANTED TO
CONSTRUCT AN EIGHTY YOU.
THE CITY REALLY USE THIS PILOT
AS A WAY TO LEARN WHAT WAS
WORKING AND WHAT WAS NOT WORKING
THREE OF EIGHTY YOU PERMITTING
PROCESS.
YOU KNOW ONE OF THE CHALLENGES
TO CONSTRUCTING EIGHTY USE IT
JUST HAS BEEN MENTIONED BEFORE.
PARTICULARLY AS WE THINK ABOUT
EIGHTY USES A POTENTIAL SOLUTION
FOR HOUSING FOR LOW INCOME
COMMUNITIES AND COMMUNITIES OF
COLOR.
IS ACCESS TO CAPITAL AND SO
THROUGH THIS PILOT PROGRAM THE
CITY HAS WORKED WITH THE
FINANCIAL INSTITUTION LOCALLY
GENESIS LA TO CREATE A LOAN
PRODUCT THAT WOULD ALLOW A
HOMEOWNER TO BORROW AGAINST THE
FUTURE VALUE OF THEIR HOME. TO
CONSTRUCT AN EIGHTY YOU AND A
CITY THROUGH SITUATIONS
INCLUDING WALLS FARGO TO EXPAND
SUCH SIMILAR --
PRODUCTS.
ANOTHER EFFORT THAT THE MAYOR'S
OFFICE HAS ENGAGED IN IS THE
CREATION OF AN EIGHTY YOU
GUIDELINES DOCUMENTED A SORT OF
A BROCHURE.
THE CITY'S PARTNERED WITH UCLA
CITY LAB TO CREATE A USER
FRIENDLY GUIDE TO HELP ASSIST
THE AVERAGE HOMEOWNER WHO MAY
NOT KNOW HOW O NAVIGATE THROUGH
THE BUILDING PERMITTING SYSTEM --
AND PROVIDES BASIC INFORMATION
ON AND AND WALKS HOMEOWNERS TO
THE PROCESS OF WORKING WITH THE
CITY WORKING WITH A LENDER AND
WORKING WITH THE CONTRACTOR TO
ACTUALLY GET.
THE EIGHTY YOU BILLS.
AND THEN FINALLY THE MAYOR'S
OFFICE WAS RECENTLY AWARDED A
BLOOMBERG INNOVATION CHALLENGE
GRANT OF ONE MILLION DOLLARS.
THE GRANT INCENTIVIZE IS
HOMEOWNERS TO BUILD EIGHTY USE
FOR PUBLIC GOODS SO REALLY --
EXPLORING.
A MODEL WHERE WE'RE LOOKING AT
ENCOURAGING HOMEOWNERS TO OPEN
THEIR BACKYARDS TO CONSTRUCT
EIGHTY USE --
TO HOUSE RECENTLY HOMELESS
INDIVIDUALS OR OTHER LOW INCOME
PEOPLE SO REALLY CONNECTING THE
HOUSING AND SECURE COMMUNITY
WITH --
FOLKS WHO ARE INTERESTED IN
BUILDING EIGHTY USE IN THEIR
BACKYARDS.
IT'S A THREE YEAR GRANT --
PROGRAM AND WORK WILL LIKELY BE
YOUR PRIZED.
SO THAT GENERALLY SUMMARIZES THE
VARIOUS WAYS THE CITY OF LOS
ANGELES BOTH IN THE PLANNING
DEPARTMENT YOU KNOW.
WORKING UNDER STATE LAW THROUGH
THE ZONING CODE AND ALSO THREE
SAM INNOVATION PROGRAMS IN THE
MAYOR'S OFFICE IS LOOKING.
TO THANKS FOR THE PRODUCTION OF
A TO USE IN OUR CITY I WOULD
JUST ADD THAT --
EIGHTY USE CONTINUE TO BE A
REALLY POPULAR APPLICATION AT
OUR DEVELOPMENT SERVICES COUNTER --
IN THE PLANNING DEPARTMENT IN
APPROXIMATELY A QUARTER OF ALL A
OF OUR NEW HOUSING UNITS IN THE
CITY OF LA ARE FOR ACCESSORY
DRAWING IN ANSELM --
WITHOUT CONCLUDE MY PRESENTATION
AND I'M HAPPY TO ANSWER ANY
QUESTIONS.
LET'S A TURNOVER COLLEAGUES ANY
MR BLOOM I WANNA JUST TAKE A
MOMENT TO THANK MISTER BLOOM FOR
HIS AUTHORSHIP OF AB TWENTY TWO
NINETY NINE AND TWO THOUSAND
SIXTEEN WHICH REALLY.
MOVE THIS CONVERSATION FORT
SIGNIFICANTLY BUT MISTER BUSH.
THANK YOU.
ASSEMBLY MEMBER CHIU --
HE QUICKLY REALIZED WE WERE ON
TO SOMETHING WHEN THAT THE BILL
WAS INTRODUCED BECAUSE THERE WAS
SO MUCH IMMEDIATE ENTHUSIASM FOR
IT IT'S AT IS OR SOMETHING --
THAT ARE POPULAR MONKS BOTH
NIMBIS AND THE EMPLOYEES UP WITH
WHICH IS A PRETTY UNUSUAL TO BE
ABLE TO GET EVERYBODY ON THE
SAME PAGE --
AND IT'S GRATIFYING TO HEAR IN
THE CITY OF LOS ANGELES --
A A THE LAST TIME I HEARD ABOUT --
TO HOW MANY APPLICATIONS ARE
BEEN THE NUMBER WAS HALF THE
NUMBER THAT TO YOU JUST
REFERENCED --
WE DID HAVE LEGISLATION LIKE ON
THE ISSUE OF POWER LINES OF A
TRYING TO RESOLVE THAT ISSUE
THAT'S A A BEEN A SOURCE OF
GREAT FRUSTRATION THAT WE
WEREN'T ABLE --
TO RESOLVE THAT --
AND THEN YOU DID MENTION THAT --
YOUR CONTINUING TO WORK ON IT OR
WE WITHIN SIGHT OF A RESOLUTION --
ON THAT I WOULD SAY WE NEED TO
HAVE CONTINUING DISCUSSIONS WITH
LADWP ON BUT I I I THINK WE'RE
CLOSER AT IDENTIFYING WHAT
POTENTIAL SOLUTIONS CAN BE I
THINK WE'RE REALLY.
HONING IN ON THE LOCAL
REGULATION AND POTENTIALLY
CHANGING THAT RIGHT LOCAL
REGULATION IN A WAY THAT STILL
CONSISTENT WITH GENERAL ORDER.
NINETY FIVE MIGHT BE A
POSSIBILITY BUT IT STILL
REQUIRES FURTHER DISCUSSIONS SO --
MAYBE GO GOOD IDEA --
IF I CAN REQUEST FOR YOU TO BE
IN TOUCH WITH MY OFFICE OF IS
MAYBE THERE'S A WAY OF HELPING
TO FACILITATE THAT CONVERSATION
SO THAT HAPPENS MORE QUICKLY
OBVIOUSLY.
THIS IS A ONE OF THE MANY TOOLS
THAT WE NEED TO BE UTILIZING TO
ADDRESS THE HOUSING CRISIS --
AND SO I WANT TO BE IS SO YOU
[inaudible]
MANAGER.
I HAVE ONE QUESTION FOR MISS
FARMER THAN ONE FOR THE WHOLE
PANEL.
YOU TOUCHED UPON THE PILOT YOU
HAVE A LOS ANGELES AROUND
FINANCING AND THIS IS A
CONSISTENT CONCERN OF HER AROUND
THE STATE OF THE CHALLENGES OF
HOMEOWNERS AND GETTING FINANCING
FOR THESE SORTS OF PROJECTS.
HERE'S WHAT LESSONS HAVE YOU
LEARNED SO FAR THE PILOT ARE
THERE THINGS THAT WE SHOULD
CONSIDER AT THE STATE LEVEL --
TO PUSH PRIDE AND SENT OTHERWISE
THE FINANCIAL INSTITUTIONS THAT
COULD BE HELPFUL HERE.
I YEAH I THINK THAT YOU KNOW WE
WE HAD SUCCESS WITH THE GENESIS
LA PROGRAM AND WE'VE BEEN
APPROACHING OTHER FINANCIAL
INSTITUTIONS AND WE ARE WE ARE
GAINING SOME TRACTION SO I I I
THINK THERE ARE SOME
OPPORTUNITIES.
TO PERHAPS TAKE THAT --
TO A BROADER LEVEL WITH
FINANCIAL INSTITUTIONS YOU KNOW
MAYBE MORE BROADLY AT THE STATE
WE'RE HAPPY TO SHARE THE DETAILS
OF THAT PROGRAM AND THAT.
PROGRAM WITH YOU --
I I THINK THAT --
WE'VE ALSO BEEN --
AS PART OF THIS --
IT INNOVATION GRANT LOOKING WAYS --
TO IN A SURVEY DIFFERENT --
HOMEOWNERS WERE INTERESTED IN
BUILDING EIGHTY USE --
TO YOU KNOW FOR FOR SOME FOR
SOME PEOPLE --
YOU KNOW ACCESS TO CAPITAL IS
NOT AS MUCH OF AN ISSUE BECAUSE
I HAVE EQUITY IN THEIR HOMES.
AND BEING ABLE TO LEVERAGE THOSE
OPPORTUNITIES --
WHERE ACCESS TO CAPITAL IS NOT
AS MUCH OF AN ISSUE TO CONNECT
THEM WITH THE LOW INCOME
COMMUNITIES AS I THINK I ANOTHER
OPPORTUNITY FOR US TO LOOK AT
TOO BUT I THINK IT'S KIND OF
TWOFOLD LOOKING AT?
EXPANDING THE LOAN PRODUCTS AND
GRANTS AVAILABLE --
AND THEN ALSO LOOKING AT WHERE
THERE IS OPPORTUNITY ALREADY
GREAT AND I WOULD JUST SAY FOR
ANY MEMBERS THE AUDIENCE
REPRESENTING FINANCIAL
INSTITUTIONS I THINK THERE'S
JUST A BROAD INTEREST AND FIGURE
OUT HOW TO DO THIS IN THE FACT
THAT.
WE HAVEN'T GOTTEN AS FAR AS WE
WANT SO FAR SUGGEST IS MORE WORK
TO BE DONE.
A BROADER QUESTION TO THE
PANELISTS IF YOU COULD --
WAVE THE MAGIC WAND AND THERE
ARE STATE LAWS THAT WERE PASSED
TOMORROW TO MOVE FORWARD AND
CONTINUE TO TURBO CHARGED.
PRODUCTION OF OF ALL THE COULD
SEE THIS IS WHAT WOULD YOU DO
AND I'M CURIOUS OR THE NEW LAWS
THAT WE SHOULD THINK ABOUT.
O OTHER ISSUES OF OF CHALLENGES
OF OF CITIES ARE OUT OF
COMPLIANCE WITH STATE LAW WONDER
HOW YOU WOULD CHARACTERIZE WHAT
WE OUGHT TO BE DOING.
WELL YES WELL WHAT WE ALL AND WE
WON'T HOLD YOU DENNIS ARE ASKING
YOU JUST BE CREATIVE IN HELPING
US THINK THIS THROUGH WELL AS I
CAN ONE OF THE ONE OF THE THINGS
THAT --
MISTER NICHOLS HIGHLIGHTED IN
HIS PRESENTATION IS THAT THERE'S
ACTUALLY THERE'S A NUMBER OF
ASPECTS OF CURRENT LAW THAT.
MAY NOT EVERY JURISDICTION IS
FULLY COMPLYING WITH SO.
AND TO ME THAT STEPS OUT AS MORE
OF AN ENFORCEMENT AND OVERSIGHT
ISSUE THEN I NEED FOR NEW
DEVELOPMENT STANDARDS AND WE
HAVE.
DEVELOPMENT STANDARDS THAT ARE
WORKING AND IN JURISDICTIONS
THAT ARE USING THEM
APPROPRIATELY WE'VE SEEN BIG
INCREASE AS AN EIGHTY YEARS --
I MEAN THE BIG ONE OF THE BIG
TAKE AWAY IS --
AGAIN TO KEEP PICKING ON ON
DAVID FROM SANTA ROSA BUT HE
SOUGHT SUCH A BIG INCREASE IN
EIGHTY PRODUCTION WHEN THE FEET --
LEVELS WERE ABLE TO BE REDUCED
SO TO THE X. ANGEL SUPPORT AND
INCENTIVES TO REDUCE THEIR FEES
SO THAT LEGITIMATE
INFRASTRUCTURE CONCERNS CAN
STILL BE ADDRESSED WHILE
REDUCING THE COST BURDEN TO TO
HOMEOWNERS TO PRODUCE EIGHTY
YEARS.
AND THAT SEEMS LIKE A A GREAT
WAY TO HELP ENCOURAGE PRODUCTION --
AND MAYBE EVEN WITH THAT SB TO
MONEY USING OTHER --
PROTOTYPES AND THE PRE APPROVED
EIGHTY YOU PLANS THOSE THOSE --
THOSE ALL SEEM LIKE SUCCESSFUL
MODELS THAT ARE IN THE WORLD
ALREADY THAT CAN LEAD TO A
FASTER EASIER APPROVED AND LOWER
COST EIGHTY YOU PRODUCTION
SOLUTIONS [inaudible]
OTHER THOUGHTS.
IN POSSIBLY WELL WE WHAT WE
OFTEN YOU DO IS JUST PROVIDE
TECHNICAL ASSISTANCE THE
CLARIFICATION OF THE LAW.
AND THERE'S SAID AND IT'S
DIFFERENT VARIOUS REASONS WHAT
WAYS SEE INTERPRETED --
AND SO WE WE WE'RE DOING THAT
AND AS THE A BOOKLET THAT WE I
THINK YOU ALL HAVE TWO THOUSAND
SIXTEEN MEMORANDUM.
IS THAT WE EXPAND ON THAT AND
PROVIDE FOR THE CLARIFICATION IN
THE IN THE FREQUENTLY ASKED
QUESTIONS SECTION.
THANK YOU MISSOURI --
I WOULD I WOULD I'D YOU KNOW WE
MY STAFF DEALS WITH A LOT OF
APPLICATIONS --
ON THE PHONE IS THERE IN TRYING
TO BUILD THESE EIGHTY USE AND
YOU KNOW OBVIOUSLY IT'S IT'S A
PROGRAM YOU KNOW WITH WHAT'S THE
STATE LAW --
GOVERNING WHERE WE'VE SEEN IT
WE'VE SEEN A LOT OF EIGHTY IS
PRODUCED IN THE CITY --
I THINK WE DEAL WITH A LOT OF A
CASE BY CASE SITUATIONS WITH OUR
BUILDING CODE IN OUR ZONING CODE
WHERE THERE ARE YOU KNOW BECAUSE
STATE LAW SORT OF SUPERSEDES OUR
LOCAL ZONING REGULATIONS AT THIS
TIME -- KIND
OF BRINGING TOGETHER UP THAT ARE
NOT SPECIFICALLY MENTIONED IN
STATE LAW AND FIGURING OUT HOW.
TO MAKE THEM WORK OUT WITH STATE
LAW -- HAS
BEEN SOMETHING WE'VE BEEN
DEALING WITH ON A CASE BY CASE
BASIS AND SO I CAN'T REALLY SAY
THAT THERE'S A UNIVERSAL.
SET OF BUILDING HAD REGULATIONS
RESIGNING CUT REGULATIONS THAT
YOU KNOW OUR OUR BARRIERS BUT WE
DO SPEND A LOT OF TIME ON A CASE
BY CASE BASIS --
KIND OF WORKING THROUGH THOSE
KINDS OF ISSUES WITH THE
APPLICANTS SO --
JUST THINKING ABOUT --
HOW DIFFERENT ZONING REGULATIONS
ACROSS THE CITY ARE STRUCTURED
RELATED TO PERMITTING AND
DEVELOPMENT OF EIGHTY IS?
COLLEAGUES IN THE FINAL
QUESTIONS TO THE PANELISTS
[inaudible]
MR PER.
JUST.
A COMMENT BECAUSE I THINK IT'S
IMPORTANT TO HAVE SOME CONTEXT --
AROUND THIS ISSUE AND HOW
IMPORTANT --
ACCELERATING THAT --
THE CONSTRUCTION OF AS MANY
IDEAS AS POSSIBLE IS --
EIGHTIES ARE NOT --
TRADITIONAL AFFORDABLE HOUSING
SO THE COMPARISON IS NOT --
DIRECT IS COSTING GOTCHA OF TEN
TIMES LESS SOMETIMES MORE ISN'T
SAN FRANCISCO IN MY AREA --
MORE THE MORE OR LESS AN AVERAGE
OF FIVE HUNDRED THOUSAND DOLLARS
PER UNIT TO BUILD A UNIT OF
AFFORDABLE HOUSING TODAY. EIGHTY
USE -- FILL
SOME OF THE NEED FOR
AFFORDABILITY BECAUSE OF THE WAY
THERE UTILIZED FOR CHILDREN FOR
PARENTS --
OFFER A VERY STEEP ON THE
COMMUNITY WHO ARE LOOKING FOR A
MORE AFFORDABLE --
ALTERNATIVE TO TRADITIONAL
HOUSING IN AN APARTMENT BUILDING
OR WHATNOT --%
AND SO WE PUT A LOT OF MONEY --
AROUND THE STATE INTO BUILDING
AFFORDABLE HOUSING.
IT ONLY CAN ONLY GO SO FAR I WAY
OF COMPARISON THE EIGHT THOUGHT
NINE ALMOST NINE THOUSAND
APPLICATIONS IN LOS ANGELES --
WHICH WE COULD EXTRAPOLATE FOR
US STATEWIDE MAYBE HCV AS THE
NUMBERS BUT IT DOESN'T MATTER.
OF A BILLION DOLLARS OF
AFFORDABLE HOUSING MONEY --
WILL PAY FOR TWO THOUSAND UNITS.
AND HERE WE HAVE A LOT CHANGE
THAT'S CREATING CLOSE TO NINE
THOUSAND UNITS JUSTIN LOS
ANGELES COUNTY --
I THINK IT'S VERY IMPORTANT FOR
US TO KIND OF FOCUS ON THE
ECONOMICS OF THIS ISSUE BECAUSE
WE ARE.
SIMPLY CANNOT PROVIDE THE
RESOURCES TO BUILD THE AMOUNT OF
AFFORDABLE HOUSING THAT WE
REALLY NEED IN THE STATE.
GOVERNOR --
IS PROMOTING A PLAN TO BUILD TWO
HUNDRED THOUSAND UNITS OF
HOUSING NOT A NOT AFFORDABLE
HOUSING BUT IF OF HOUSING --
PER YEAR --
AND TO THIS IS AN IMPORTANT TOOL
TO GETTING.
THANK YOU FOR THAT COMMENT OTHER
MICHAEL I THINK THE GOVERNOR'S
PROPOSED ONLY THREE POINT FIVE
MILLION UNITS OF THE NEXT EIGHT
YEARS WHICH IS CLOSER TO FOUR
HUNDRED THOUSAND UNITS SO IT.
YOUR YOUR YOUR POINT IS WELL
TAKEN EXCEPT THE NUMBERS EVEN
BIGGER SO EXACTLY --
WITH THAT I WANT TO THANK THE
PANELISTS FOR YOUR GREAT --
PRESENTATIONS IF I COULD ASK ALL
OF THE WITNESSES TODAY TO PROVE
TO PROVIDE TO OUR COMMITTEES
YOUR WRITTEN TESTIMONY WERE
HAPPY -- TO
PULL THAT TOGETHER GET IT TO ALL
OF OUR COMMITTEE MEMBERS AND TO
THE MEMBERS OF THE PUBLIC.
I'M GONNA TURN IT BACK OVER TO
MY FELLOW CHAIR TO PRESIDE OVER
PUBLIC COMMENT.
ABOUT.
GOOD AFTERNOON ALL THOSE OF YOU
IN THE AUDIENCE --
IT'S TIME FOR PUBLIC TEST
TESTIMONY AND LIKELY TO FORM A
LINE OVER HERE ON THE RIGHT --
IF YOU COULD KEEP YOUR COMMENTS
AS BRIEF AS POSSIBLE AND ALSO
REMEMBER THAT YOU ALWAYS CAN
SEND EMAILS TO OUR COMMITTEES IF
YOU HAVE ANY ISSUES THAT WE DID
NOT ADDRESS A THERE.
ARE OTHER CHALLENGES --
WE'D APPRECIATE YOU JUST TELLING
US YOUR NAME AND WHO YOU
REPRESENT THANK YOU.
THE MORNING --
TRACY RYAN THROW COUNTY
REPRESENTS OF CALIFORNIA --
ALSO HERE FOR THE CALIFORNIA
STATE THESE OTHER URBAN --
COALITION COUNTIES AND THE
LEAGUE OF CALIFORNIA CITIES --
JUST A NUMBER OF AREAS OF
CONCERN OR ISSUES THAT WE WOULD
LIKE TO SEE AS PART OF THE
DISCUSSION THIS YEAR --
AS WE MOVE FORWARD --
WE BELIEVE THAT LOCAL
GOVERNMENTS NEED GOVERNMENTS
NEED TO CONTINUE TO HAVE
DISCRETION OVER LIMITING EIGHTY
YOU CONSTRUCTION IN AREAS THAT
HAVE REAL PUBLIC --
HAZARDS --
SUCH AS HIGH A FIRE RISK --
IN SIMILARLY WE LIKE TO SEE
SETBACK REQUIREMENTS BEING UNDER
THE DISCRETION OF LOCAL
GOVERNMENTS FOR THE SAME REASON.
HAVING SOME DEFENSIBLE SPACE IN
SOME OF THOSE UNINCORPORATED
RURAL AREAS --
PARCEL SIZE WE LIKE TO SEE THAT
CONTINUE TO BE --
PART OF THE CONVERSATION.
IN UNINCORPORATED AREAS AND
RURAL AREAS PERSONAL SIZES AWAY --
TO ENSURE THAT --
THAT WE HAVE THE CAPACITY
ESPECIALLY WITH SEWER SEPTIC
SYSTEMS AND A LOT OF RURAL AREAS
WE DON'T HAVE PUBLIC WATER IT'S
USUALLY A A SEPTIC SYSTEM.
AS YOU KNOW WHY AS PART OF THE
BUDGET --
FUNDS FOR REPAIR FOR SEWERS --
AND SO THAT'S A REAL ISSUE AND
DISADVANTAGED COMMUNITIES IN
RURAL AREAS SO WE LIKE TO MAKE
SURE THAT CONTINUES TO BE A CAN
CAN --
CONVERSATION.
AND WE WANT TO MAKE SURE AS IT
HAS BEEN THE PAST THAT THE
CONVERSATION ABOUT THE IMPACTS
BETWEEN --
NEW STRUCTURES AND THOSE
INCORPORATE INTO ESTABLISH
STRUCTURES --
CONTINUES TO BE THERE --
LIKEWISE WITH MULTI FAMILY
DWELLINGS THE IMPACTS FROM.
ADDING EIGHTY USED TO MULTI
FAMILY DWELLINGS IS IS VERY
DIFFERENT THAN THOSE IN.
A GROUP A GARAGE CONVERSION FOR
INSTANCE.
LASTLY JUST TO BE VERY BRIEF I
THINK TAT WE NEED TO HAVE A
REASONABLE DISCUSSION ABOUT FEES
I KNOW THIS IS.
THE ISSUE THAT MOST OF US HAVE
BEEN TALKING ABOUT I THINK THAT --
WE NEED THAT CONVERSATION NEEDS
TO BE --
AWAIT THAT WE CAN THE SENATE
BUYS --
EIGHTY USE IN AREAS WHERE
APPROPRIATE --
BUT ALSO ENSURE THAT EIGHTEEN
THE INFRASTRUCTURE OR CREATE NEW
INFRASTRUCTURE WHERE IT'S
NECESSARY --
WE'D ALSO LIKE TO ACKNOWLEDGE
THAT -- THE
SERVICES THAT ARE PROVIDED BY
THE LOCAL GOVERNMENTS --
OUR CD'S THAT THAT MUST BE OF
FUNDED FOR INSTANCE PERMITTING
INSPECTIONS AND DOCUMENT
RECORDING SO WE NEED TO MAKE
SURE THAT THOSE ARE FUNDED --
AS THEIR ESSENTIAL --
IN CLOSING WE LOOK FORWARD TO
GETTING THE CONVERSATION THANK
YOU.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
MORNING AROUND ROSSI WITH THE
CALIFORNIA SPECIAL DISTRICTS
ASSOCIATION. FOR THE SAKE OF
BREVITY I'VE JUST LIKE TO
ASSOCIATE MY COMMENTS --
WITH THOSE OF MY COLLEAGUE FROM
EAST BAY MUD WAS ON THE PANEL
EARLIER --
SPECIALLY FOR THE CONNECTION
CAPACITY CHARGES THESE FEES ARE
VERY IMPORTANT FOR OUR WATER AND
SEWER DISTRICTS AND THEY ARE
VERY MUCH HELP ENABLE.
OUR DISTRICTS TO PROVIDE THE
CRITICAL INFRASTRUCTURE NEEDED
TO ACTUALLY PROVIDE WATER AND
SEWER SERVICE TO THOSE HOMES.
ADDITIONALLY FOR OUR PARKING
FIRE DISTRICTS THEIR ALSO
HEAVILY RELIANT ON THE IMPACT
FEES FOR OUR FIRE DISTRICTS IN
PARTICULAR WITH THE WILD FIRES
SPREADING ACROSS THE STATE IT'S
VERY IMPORTANT THAT THEY ARE
ABLE.
TO PURCHASE NEW FIRE TRACKS TO
EXPAND THEIR EXISTING FACILITIES
TO ACCOUNT FOR THE ADDITIONAL
POPULATION.
AND AS WELL FOR PARK THIS ON
IMPACT FEES WE'VE ACTUALLY HEARD
FROM A FEW OF OUR PARK DISTRICTS
THAT THEY RELY ON IMPACT FEES.
FOR UP 275% OF THEIR FUNDING IN
A GIVEN YEAR STURGIS WOULD LIKE
TO THANK THE COMMITTEES FOR
TAKING A LOOK AT THESE ISSUES
THIS YEAR AND LOOKING FORWARD TO
WORKING WITH YOU IN THE FUTURE
THANK YOU.
A MANAGER DAVID JONES OF HALF
THE TOWN OF TRUCKEE VERY MUCH
AND IN SUPPORT OF AB USE THEY
LIKE THE COMMITTEE TO LOOK IN
THE BARRIERS PERSON BY H. AWAY
AS WE'VE GOT A NUMBER OF
RESIDENTS THAT WANT TO BUILD.
AN H. WAYS OF REPRESENT A LARGE
PORTION OF HOUSING CALIFORNIA
THANK YOU.
GOOD MORNING CHRIS ANDERSON WITH
ASSOCIATION OF CALIFORNIA WATER
AGENCIES I'D LIKE TO THINK THAT
CHAIRS AND STAFF OF BOTH
COMMITTEES FOR HOLDING THIS
INFORMATIONAL HEARING TODAY AND
I'D LIKE TO CONCUR WITH THE
COMMENTS MADE BY EAST BAY MUD IN
REGARDS TO A CONNECTION FEES AND
CAPACITY CHARGES.
THESE FEES REFLECT THE
REASONABLE IN PROPORTION ACOSTA
PROVIDING AN ACTUAL SERVICE TO
CUSTOMERS WHICH APPEARS TO THE
CONSTITUTIONAL MANDATE AND
PROPOSITION --
TWO EIGHTEEN MAINTAINING THE
LANGUAGE AND SB.
TEN SIXTY NINE IN REFERENCE TO
THESE FEES.
WOULD ENSURE PUBLIC WATER
AGENCIES CAN ADEQUATE SERVICE
THEIR CUSTOMERS WHILE STILL
INCENTIVIZING HOMEOWNERS TO MEET
THE DEVELOPMENT.
MEET ENOUGH EIGHTY IS THAT --
TO MEET CALIFORNIA'S HOUSING
DEVELOPMENT GOALS.
AGAIN LIKE TO THANK THE
COMMITTEE FOR ENGAGING ON THIS
ISSUE AN AWKWARD LOOKS FORWARD
TO WORKING WITH YOU GOING
FORWARD THANK YOU.
GOOD MORNING JESSICA GEIGER WITH
THE CALIFORNIA ASSOCIATION OF
SANITATION AGENCIES I JUST WANT
TO TOUCH BRIEFLY ON THE WATER.
AND SEWER CONNECTION CAPACITY
CHARGES NOT TO BE A BROKEN
RECORD HERE BUT SO AS WAS
MENTIONED BY THE THE CONNECTION
CAPACITY FEES ARE UNIQUE IN THAT
THEY REPRESENT THE COST OF
BUYING INTO THE CAPACITY OF THE
SYSTEM --
AND PAYING FOR THE ADDITIONAL
BURDEN THAT A NEW UNIT ADDS TO
THE SYSTEM SO THESE ARE ONE TIME
FEES THEY REALLY CANNOT BE
RECOVERED BY.
SHIFTING THE CAPACITY COSTS ON
GOING RATES ARE SERVICE CHARGES --
THAT IS PROBLEMATIC UNDER PROP
TWO EIGHTEEN IMPROPER.
TWENTY SIX IN THAT IT COULD
POTENTIALLY CONSTITUTION AND AND
LEGAL SUBSIDIZATION OF FEES SO
WE ALSO CAN'T JUST ELIMINATE.
CASTING CONNECTION FEES BECAUSE
THAT ALSO SHIPS THE COSTBURDEN
ONTO ANOTHER CLASS OF REPAIRS
WHICH IS AGAIN ILLEGAL IN THE
CONSTITUTION SO --
WE ARE CONSTRAINED IN THE
CIRCUMSTANCES WHERE WE CAN
CHARGE CONNECTION IN CAPACITY
FEES THIS WAS NEGOTIATED IN SB
TEN SIXTY NINE SEVERAL YEARS AGO
SO WE CAN ONLY CHARGE A FEE FOR
A NEW --
DETACHED UNIT THEM AND THAT HE
HAS TO BE PROPORTIONAL --
BASED ON EITHER THE SQUARE
FOOTAGE OF THE YEAR NEW UNIT OR
THE NUMBER OF PLUMBING FIXTURES
IN THE UNIT.
SO -- WHEN
SB TEN SIXTY NINE SB TWO TWENTY
NINE OR AND --
I ENACTED SEVERAL YEARS AGO ARE
AGENCIES HAD TO GO BACK REVIEW
AND RENEGOTIATE THEIR RATE
STRUCTURES TO ACCOMMODATE THOSE --
THOSE NEW PREVENTION SO THE
POINT IS WE'RE ALREADY PRETTY
CONSTRAINED IN --
WHEN WE CAN CHARGE FEES CAN
REMAIN IT'S WHAT THE
CONSTITUTION LOOK FORWARD TO
WORKING WITH OF COMMITTEES --
AS THIS ISSUE PROGRESSES
THROUGHOUT THE YEAR THANK YOU
VERY MUCH.
HI MY NAME'S DON CASEY I'M WITH
CALIFORNIA RENTERS LEGAL
ADVOCACY AND EDUCATION FUND --
I WORKED PRIMARILY CONSISTS OF
HELPING OUT HOMEOWNERS WHO ARE
LOOKING TO BUILD A TO USE AND
WHERE WE SEE A ISSUE WITH
COMPLIANCE WITH STATE LAW
ENCOURAGING CITIES.
TO BRING THEIR ORDINANCES AND
COMPLIANCE --
I WANT TO HIGHLIGHT A COUPLE
ISSUES FIRST IS A LOT OF CITIES
HAVE AFFECTED BANDS ON EIGHTY
USE THROUGH.
ADOPTED ORDINANCES AND THEY DO
THIS BY PRIMARILY SETBACK
REQUIREMENTS A MINIMUM LOT SIZE
REQUIREMENTS THAT MAKE.
MOST OF THE SINGLE FAMILY LOTS
IN THAT CITY --
UNABLE TO HAVE EIGHTY USE BUT
THEY CAN ALSO DO THROUGH LIVE
COVERAGE FLOOR AREA.
OR OPEN SPACE RESTRICTIONS --
REQUIREMENTS.
AND SECOND AT I THINK A LOT OF
CITIES ARE STILL TRYING TO
IMPLEMENT DISCRETION REVIEW
PROVISIONS. TO REVIEW A FEW
APPLICATIONS AND THIS WOULD BE
EITHER THROUGH ORDINANCES THAT
ARE OUT COMPLIANCE WITH STATE
LAW.
OR BY WAY OF PROVIDING WAIVERS
TO THE THE AFFECTED BANDS THAT I
JUST MENTIONED --
THROUGH A LIKE VARIANCE PROCESS
OF SOME SORT --
I THINK.
IN LOOKING AT THE ISSUES GOING
FORWARD LIKE.
LIMITING LIMITING THOSE
REQUIREMENTS THAT EFFECTIVELY
BAN EIGHTY YEARS AND ALSO
STREAMLINING THE PERMITTING
REQUIREMENT WOULD BE IMPORTANT.
LAST THEY JUST WANT --
TO ECHO THE CONCERNS ABOUT FEES
THAT WERE EXPRESSED EARLIER --
I THINK THE CHALLENGE THERE IS
MOSTLY IN.
LIMITING THE CITIES OF THE WORST
OFFENDERS HAVE THE THE HIGHEST
FEES --
THANKS AND I LOOK FORWARD TO
CONVERSATIONS GOING PORT.
GOOD MORNING SAYS AND NOT AN ACT
HERE ON BEHALF OF HABITAT FOR
HUMANITY CALIFORNIA --
WE ARE REALLY GRATEFUL FOR THE
CONVERSATION TODAY --
HABITAT FOR HUMANITY ACTUALLY
BILLS AT USE IN CERTAIN
JURISDICTIONS A FEW OF OUR
AFFILIATES HAVE BEEN BUILDING
LOW INCOME DEED RESTRICTED
EIGHTY USE --
BUT MANY HAVE EXPRESSED FEES
BEING A LARGE BIRD AND I KNOW
THERE WAS A CONVERSATION TODAY
ABOUT AFFORDABLE EIGHTY USE AND
HOW -- THOSE
ARE MOVING THROUGHOUT THE STATE --
MANY OF OUR AFFILIATES HAVE
EXPRESSED INTEREST IN BUILDING
ADDITIONALLY TO USE.
TO HOUSE MORE THAN JUST ONE
FAMILY IN MANY INSTANCES BUT
HAVE EXPRESSED THAT FEES --
HAVE BEEN A LARGE BURDEN FOR
THEM AND SO WE'RE EXCITED TO
HEAR ABOUT SOME OF THE PROGRAMS
THAT ARE OCCURRING.
IN OTHER JURISDICTIONS --
WAIVERS OR INCENTIVE PROGRAMS
AND LOOK FORWARD TO WORKING WITH
YOU ALL --
TO CONTINUE THAT CONVERSATION
ABOUT HOW WE CAN BUILD MORE
EIGHTY USE AND ESPECIALLY
AFFORDABLE IT USE THANK YOU.
PATRICK WELL TO THE CALIFORNIA
MUNICIPAL UTILITIES ASSOCIATION
REPRESENTING OVER SIXTY
MUNICIPALLY OWNED ELECTRIC AND
WATER UTILITIES ROUND THE STATE
ALL ALIGNER COMMENTS WITH THE
SANITATION DISTRICTS IN AQUA
THANK YOU.
AT LUIS BRONTE WITH CALIFORNIA
BE I JUST WANTED TO THANK THE
COMMITTEES FOR THEIR FOCUS ON
THIS IMPORTANT ISSUE. EIGHTY USE
CAN BE A A BELOW MARKET RATE
ALTERNATIVE TO COMMENSURATE --
MARKET RATE OF WHAT WELL BOTH
WOULD BE MARGAERY BUT AT IS ARE
ARE USUALLY CHEAPER THAN
COMMENDABLE MARKET RATE UNITS IN
PART IN BUILDING SO THEY CAN BE
AN EFFECTIVE STRATEGY BOTH FOR
FOR NATURALLY OCCURRING
AFFORDABLE HOUSING.
AS WELL AS AN OPTION FOR FOR
PURSUE MULTI GENERATIONAL
HOUSEHOLDS --
DEFINITELY WANT TO FOCUS ON THE
FEE ISSUE THIS YEAR AND IN THAT
THE ISSUES AROUND ALLOWING OWNER
OCCUPANCY THOSE ARE BIG
CHALLENGES FOR BUILDING EIGHTY
USING LOTS OF COMMUNITIES.
NOT NOT IN NOT IN CERTAIN PLACES
BUT IN IN IN SOME CITIES WE SEE
EXCESSIVE FEES.
PARK IMPACT FEES FOR EXAMPLE OF
OF FORTY TO SIXTY THOUSAND
DOLLARS PER UNIT --
WHICH ARE REALLY JUST INTENDED
NOT NOT TO MITIGATE FOR IMPACT
BUT TO REALLY CURB DEVELOPMENT
THERE.
ADDITIONALLY WE HAVE HEARD FROM
MANY HOMEOWNERS THAT THE OWNER
OCCUPANCY REQUIREMENTS IMPOSED
BY CITIES A CAN OFTEN LIMIT
THEIR ABILITY TO ACCESS CAPITAL
BECAUSE BANKS GET REALLY
SKITTISH.
WHEN THEIR DEED RESTRICTIONS ON
WHAT YOU CAN DO WITH THE ASSET
AFTER IT'S BEEN BUILT?
THAT'S THAT'S BEEN A BIG BIG
CHALLENGE.
WERE SYMPATHETIC TO THE THE THE
THE CONCERNS FROM A CITIES LIKE
SANTA ROSA WHICH REQUIRE CERTAIN
AMOUNTS OF AFFORDABILITY --
FOR WAITING THAT OWNER OCCUPANCY
REQUIREMENT BUT I THINK THERE'S
A MIDDLE GROUND THERE TO STRIKE
BETWEEN CITIES THAT HAVE THOSE
THOSE EXISTING PROGRAMS.
THAT ENCOURAGE AFFORDABLE
HOUSING AND THEN ALSO ALLOWING
SIT AT FOLKS WHO LIVE IN MORE
BAD ACTORS CITIES THAT WOULD
HAVE ACCESS TO CAPITAL ISSUES.
AS AGAIN JUST WANTED THINK
COMMITTEES FOR THEIR FOCUS ON IS
REALLY IMPORTANT HOUSING
STRATEGY AND LOOK FORWARD TO
WORKING WITH THAT THAT SIMPLY --
GOING FORWARD.
GOOD MORNING AGAIN TIM SU FOR
SPEAKING AS A MEMBER OF THE
PUBLIC FROM SAN FRANCISCO.
PERSONAL EXPERIENCE YOU MIGHT
WANT TO HAVE THIS ON YOUR LIST
IS THAT BANKING CRITERIA IN THE
PAST HAS PENALIZED.
IN EIGHTY YOU --
SPEAKING FROM OUR X. YOU ARE
ELEVATED FROM THE LOWEST COST
LENDING WHEN YOU GO FROM A
SINGLE FAMILY TO WHAT OFTENTIMES
THE BANKS CONSIDER A MULTI UNIT
BUILDING.
SO YOU DON'T GET THAT LOWEST
RATE WE WE ACTUALLY EXPERIENCE
THAT WERE WE WERE KICKED UP INTO
A HIGHER RATE OF FINANCING WHICH
ON THE FACE OF IT MAKES NO SENSE
BECAUSE THE ADDITION OF THE
EIGHTY YOU PROBABLY ADDED.
CONSERVATIVELY MANY SIX FIGURES
TO THE APPRAISED VALUE OF OUR OF
OUR HOME SO SOMETHING FOR
CONSIDERATION.
THANK YOU.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH FOR PUBLIC
COMMENT THE CLOSES PUBLIC
COMMENT ODD JUST A COUPLE OF
FINAL COMMENTS ON MY PART --
THERE WERE A FEW COMMENTERS WHO
MENTIONED THE IMPACT OF SETBACKS
AND LOT AREAS.
ON THIS AND I WOULD WITH I WOULD
LOVE TO GET SOME MORE WRITTEN
TESTIMONY ON THAT IF POSSIBLE AS
WELL AS THE IMPACT ON THE
DISCRETIONARY REVIEW PROCESS --
AS WELL AS I HAD NOT HEARD THAT
POINT AROUND BANKING CRITERIA SO
IF YOU WANT TO GET A SOME MORE
INFORMATION ABOUT THAT THAT
WOULD BE APPRECIATED.
I WANT TO THANK ALL THE
PANELISTS --
ALL THE MEMBERS OF THE PUBLIC
THAT CAME TO TESTIFY --
AS WELL AS OUR OUR LOCAL
GOVERNMENT COMMITTEE AND ARE
GREAT CO CHAIR OF THAT COMMITTEE --
THIS IS CERTAINLY A TOPIC
REDUCED AND MY EXPECTATION IS A
NUMBER OF OTHERS --
AND SO WE WANT TO USE THIS AS A
CHANCE TO START THAT THESE
ISSUES --
DEVELOPER PERSPECTIVE ON THEM --
BUT WILL CERTAINLY BE TRYING TO
WRESTLE WITH SOME OF THESE
COMPLICATED ISSUES.
I CERTAINLY AGREE WITH THE
SENTIMENT EARLIER THAT --
THAT THIS IS A FORM OF HOUSING
THAT WE NEED TO SUPPORT --
AS AS AS AS MOST SIGNIFICANTLY
AS WE CAN --
MISTER BLOOM I THINK LAID IT OUT
VERY WELL THAT THIS IS A VERY
COST EFFECTIVE WAY FOR US --
TO IMPACT THE HOUSING CRISIS AND
DO IT IN A WAY THAT --
HAS -- THE
LEAST IMPACT ON THE EXISTING
CHARACTER OF OUR COMMUNITIES --
BRINGING TOGETHER WHAT ARE
TYPICALLY WORN STAKEHOLDERS SO
IT'S MY HOPE THAT WE'LL BE ABLE
TO MOVE MORE POLICIESTHIS YEAR
THAT -- MOVE
THAT FORWARD --
WITH THAT LOOK FOR TO FUTURE
DISCUSSIONS AND I WANT TO ASK.
OUR GREAT CHAIR OF LOCAL
GOVERNMENT IF YOU HAVE ANY FINAL
COMMENTS FINAL COMMENTS JUST IS
THAT --
THOSE REALLY AUDIENCE OR ELSE OR
PLEASE TAKE A LOOK AT OUR WEB
PAGES WE HAVE INFORMATION WHEN
WE'RE HAVING OUR HEARINGS.
THE DOCUMENTATIONS ARE OUT THERE
AND POSTED ON WE IF YOU WANT TO
RIP UP WITH YOUR INPUT PLEASE
LET US KNOW EARLIER THAN LATER
BUT YOU'RE MORE THAN WELCOME TO
ATTEND OUR MEETINGS.
ON THIS IS IMPORTANT TOPIC AS WE
ALL KNOW --
WE'RE LOOKING FOR TO SEE HOW WE
CAN MOVE THIS PROCESS ALONG A
LITTLE FASTER AND I APPRECIATE
THE CONVERSATION ABOUT RURAL AND
I ALSO WANT TO THINK --
SANTA ROSA WE DID HAVE TO THINK
THEY HAD TO THINK OUT OF THE BOX
AND MAYBE IT'S NOT OF WHAT
EVERYBODY WANTS BUT I THINK THAT
THEY HAD TO DO IT'S REALLY GOOD
FOR THE COMMUNITY AND I WANT TO
THANK THEM. FOR MOVING ON TO TO
MAKING SURE OUR WE HAVE PEOPLE
WITH A ROOF OVER THEIR HEAD SO
THANK YOU VERY MUCH [inaudible]
GREAT.
WITHOUT ANY FINAL COMMENTS WITH
THAT TODAY'S COMMITTEE IS
RECESSED